NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO ONE OR TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW I
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 1-877-226-8152 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO SIX NINE
SEVEN NINE ONE FOUR FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
MARKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE AND FOR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
PERSISTS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATE TO CALL YOUR LINE. AT
THE TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTED
AND YOU ARE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY ENJOYED
ACOUSTIC FOR FEEDBACK YOU MUST
MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING. SECURING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THE
CONNECTIONS NEEDED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT A HEARING IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME
LATIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS FOR
JUSTIN TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE
TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENTS ALL.
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
DUE TO COULD. REGARDING LENGTH
OF. TECHNO CONSIDERATIONS IN
CLEANING PROTOCOLS WE WILL
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. ACCORDINGLY WITNESS
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION WILL
BE LIMITED TO THREE MINUTES
EACH ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY DURING PUBLIC COMMENT.
MUST LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO
THE NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURES. TODAY
WE HAVE TO TWELVE BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA WE HAVE THREE
BILLS ON CONSENT THOSE BILLS
ARE. AS BEFORE NINE SEVEN SB
FIVE FOUR NINE SB SIX FOUR
EIGHT. SB FIVE ONE FIVE HAS
BEEN PULLED AT THE AUTHOR'S
REQUEST I'M ALSO PULLING SB
SIXTY FIVE FROM TODAY'S HEARING
AS THE AUTHOR IS AWARE I AM
INCREDIBLY INTERESTED AND
COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING.
MATERNAL AND INFANT MORTALITY
AND THE VAST DISPARITIES SEEN
ACROSS THE STATE I APPRECIATE
THE EFFORTS MADE BY THE AUTHOR
TO ADDRESS INEQUITIES. BUT AS
CURRENTLY STRUCTURED THE BILL
DOES NOT PURCHASE COUNTIES HAVE
THE HIGHEST PREVALENCE OF
MATERNAL AND INFANT MORTALITY.
I HAVE OTHER CONCERNS AS WELL
WHICH I'VE SHARED WITH THE
AUTHORED THIS BILL NEEDS A LOT
OF WORK AND CAREFUL
CONSIDERATION. THEREFORE I'M
PULLING THE THIS BILL FROM THE
HEARING TODAY BUT LET'S START
WITH THE STOP MOTION A QUORUM
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND CONTINUE- AT. WE
DO. FIVE OKAY WE DO. UNTIL THEN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PORTATO
HERE. RETARDER HERE JONES
CORTESE CORTESE HERE COM LONGER
CAN HERE AND HERE. OKAY AND- WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED A FORMIDABLE.
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN- TO
HEAR THE FIRST BILL ON THE
AGENDA ITEM WHICH IS AGENDA
ITEM TO AND SENATOR SKINNER'S
HERE TO PRESENT SENATOR SKINNER
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN
YOU ARE READY. MADAM CHAIRS-
ITEM TO SB. THREE SIX FOUR. YES
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER TWO SENATE
BILL THREE SIX COUNTY AGENDA IN
FRONT OF ME I'D- AND- I WOULD
ONLY LIKE TO REGISTER THAT I
WAS ONLY INFORMED THAT SB SIXTY
FIVE WAS BEING PULLED ABOUT
BABY HALF HOUR AGO. SO AND- I
JUST WANT TO PUT THAT ON THE
RECORD. SB THREE SIXTY FOUR. SB.
THREE SIXTY FOUR. IS IN EFFECT
A VERY SIMPLE CONCEPT AND THAT
IS THAT WE PROVIDE FREE
EDUCATION NOW THAT IS OUR
POLICY SO EVERY CHILD AT EVERY
K. THROUGH TWELVE STUDENT
CALIFORNIA IS ABLE TO ATTEND A
PUBLIC SCHOOL FREE OF CHARGE.
WE KNOW THAT CHILDREN THAT ARE
FED NUTRITIOUS MEALS I'M NOT
HUNGRY DO MUCH BETTER IN CHOOL
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE CAN BE
A VARIETY OF REASONS WHY A
CHILD MAY SHOW UP AT SCHOOL.
NOT HAVING YET BEEN FED AND
THAT IS OBVIOUSLY THOSE
CHILDREN WHOSE FAMILIES ARE-
HAVE ECONOMIC HARDSHIPS OR
OTHERS MAY FALL INTO THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE MORE THAN OTHER
CHILDREN BUT ANY CHILD COULD BE
IN THE SITUATION WHERE THEY-
ARRIVE AT SCHOOL. AND HAVEN'T
BEEN ADEQUATELY FED AND THUS
ARE NOT AS ABLE TO PERFORM WELL
AT SCHOOL. SO WHAT SB THREE
SIXTY FOUR DOES IS IN THE SAME
WAY THAT WE PROVIDE FREE
SCHOOL. IT ENSURES THAT OUR
CHILDREN ARE FED A FREE MEAL.
NOW THE BENEFIT OF THAT BESIDES
THE FACT THAT WE WOULD HAVE.
MUCH BETTER OUTCOMES AT SCHOOL
IS THAT WE REMOVE THE STIGMA.
FROM THOSE CHILDREN WHO WE DO
HAVE A PROGRAM AND ITS FOR
FEDERALLY SUPPORTED FOR. FREE
AND REDUCED LUNCH AND MANY
CHILDREN GET THEN THE MEAL FREE
OTHER CHILDREN ONLY PAY A
PARTIAL COST. BUT FOR MANY
CHILDREN THERE'S A STIGMA TO
THAT WE ALSO HAVE A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE SOME PARENTS
ARE EITHER AREN'T AWARE OR
DON'T HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
APPLY. AND IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
A FREE MEAL THE- SCHOOL HAS TO
GO THROUGH A LOT OF
BUREAUCRATIC ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURE TO GET PARENTS TO
APPLY. FOR THE- OR THE GUARDIAN
TO APPLY FOR THE FREE AND
REDUCED LUNCH THAN DOING INCOME
VERIFICATION. AND THEN- THE
CHILD IS- THEN PROVIDED IS A
SAID EITHER A PARTIAL- EIGHT
HAVE TO PARTIALLY PAY OR FREE
MEALS. NOW THIS BILL WHAT IS
AYE INDICATE PUT US ON THE
PATHWAY OF FREE MEALS AT
SCHOOL. AND IT WOULD ALSO HELP
US MAXIMIZE THE FEDERAL MONEY.
THAT WE RECEIVED TO HELP COVER
THOSE COSTS. AT&T ADDITIONALLY
IN THE BILL THERE IS A GRANT
PROGRAM THAT BUILDS UPON AN
EXISTING PROGRAM THAT THE
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DISTRICTS NOW PARTICIPATE IN.
WHICH IS CONNECTS THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WITH CALIFORNIA FOOD
PRODUCERS AND FARMERS. AND
ALLOWS THEM THEY THEN PURCHASE
DIRECTLY AND THE CHILDREN ARE
THEN OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE A
SUPPORT FOR CALIFORNIA FARMERS
BUT ALSO IN GENERAL BECAUSE WE
ARE THE BURKE A FRUIT AND
VEGETABLE AND SUCH A
PRODUCER'S. BID IS HEALTHIER
AND FOOD ALSO THE AT THOSE
SCHOOLS SO. THOSE ARE THE
THINGS THAT. THIS BILL DOES AND
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE MY- ROCIO
PEREA THIS FOR THE CENTER FOR
LAW AND SOCIAL POLICY SPEAK AND
ALSO CRYSTAL FITZSIMONS FROM
THE FOOD RESEARCH AND ACTION
CENTER. AND WILL BEGIN WITH THE
FIRST LEAD SUPPORT TO TESTIFY
ON THIS BILL. PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. MODERATED WE HAVE
PRESS ZERO PRESS ON THE LINE. I
AM LOOKING FOR THAT NAME RIGHT
NOW HERE- IF THEY ARE AND THE
CALL THEIR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
HI APRIL ZERO. YES IN WHEN
YOU'RE READY WE'RE POLITICS
WITH THAT NO PROBLEM GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME MY NAME IS STILL BETTER AND
I AM AN EMERSON A LITTLE THAT
WAS FORMALLY PLACE BUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS DURING MY TIME WITH C. A.
S. B. I RESEARCH THE IMPACT OF
PANDEMIC EBT OUR FAMILY IN
CALIFORNIA. PANDEMIC AB T. WAS
A TEMPORARY EMERGENCY CALL MEAL
REPLACEMENT NUTRITION BENEFIT
THAT WOULD FEDERALLY AUTHORIZED
IN THE FAMILY TRICKS
CORONAVIRUS RESPOND BACK B. B.
T. WAS LOADED ONTO AN EBT CARD
FOR CHILDREN WHO ARE ARTISTICAL
MAIL DUE TO PROBATE RELATED
SCHOOL CLOSURES REACHING OVER
THREE POINT. SEVEN MILLION KIDS
IN CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE ELIGIBLE
FOR KEY B. T. S. HI TO ALLOCATE
FOR MEAL. CHILDREN COULD READ
IT WORK I THEIR BETTER OR-
STATUS OF THEIR PARENTS. MY
READ PRIMARILY BASED ON A
SURVEY THAT RECEIVED OVER A
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED RESPONSES
FROM PDP RECIPIENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. MOST IMPORTANTLY I
FOUND THAT P. B. T. HELP KEEP
CHILDREN NOURISHED AND HEALTHY
WHILE ALSO EASING OTHER
FINANCIAL BURDENS IMPACTING
FAMILIES WOULD SECURITY. OVER
HALF OF RESPONDENTS SAID THAT
PDP QUOTE REDUCE OUR WORRIES
AND PAYING OTHER HEALTH
EXPENSIVE BIKE BRAND OF THE
TRUTH YOU KNOW THE PHONE. AND
THAT P. B. T. QUOTE STRETCH OUR
FOOD. BUDGET FOR OUR WHOLE
FAMILY. DESPITE OVERALL BENEFIT
THAT P. CARD. BBC WEATHER.
PROGRAM AND WOULD NOT FOR TO
KEEP CHILDREN NOURISH. MOST
FAMILIES COME TO BE BETTER WERE
ADDITIONAL QUICKLY THANK CHECK
MEALS AND GROWTH FROM THANK.
YOU STRETCH FOOD BY. BUT THE
FACT THE PDP PROVIDE AND ALLOW
PROBLEM TO PAY BLUE AND WHITE
WORKING FOR THEM. WELL ONE OF
THE MAIN REASONS REASONS WHY
WE'RE THE- ONE SEED RECIPIENTS
SHARE. EDT HARPER GET MORE ARE
NOT. BUT MY HOW AND I HAVE LOST
THEIR YOUR THE KIND. I WE USED
BUT THEY TO THEY GROUP HAD TO
PAY FOR BILLS AND RENT. I DON'T
KNOW WE WOULD HAVE DONE WITHOUT
PDP. ANOTHER SHARED HE BEAT THE
HELL MY FOR A LOT BECAUSE WERE
IN A POSITION WHERE WE TO GET
WHETHER TO TAKE BILL OR BY.
WHEN I P. CARD RIGHT THEY ARE
VERY IN REDUCING RISK ABOUT
BUYING. EVEN IF REJECT AND OVER.
SPOKE TO THE NEED FOR BERMAN
YEAR OVER SOLUTION EXPERTS.
HOME THERE ARE AVAILABLE TO ALL
CODES CAN REGARD OF MAKE.
STATUS WHEN SCHOOLS ARE CLOSE.
WHAT I DON'T TINY. ARE LIKE PBT.
FAMILIES CAN CLEARED YET BUT
ABILITY THANK YOU THEIR CHILD
URGED YOUR LONG. NOT JUST ONE
CALL. ARE OPEN. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR. THANK YOU AND UP TO WE
HAVE TO FOUR TO TWO CRYSTAL A
MODERATE CAN YOU- OPEN THE LINE
HER. ALAINA NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CRYSTAL
CONFINEMENT THE DIRECTOR OF
SCHOOL AND OUT OF SCHOOL TIME
PROGRAMS FOR THE FOOD RESEARCH
AND ACTION PLAN ARE COMMONLY
KNOWN AS TRACK WHICH IS THE
LEADING NATIONAL ANTI HUNGER
ORGANIZATION WORKING TO ENSURE
THAT ALL PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES HAVE ACCESS TO A HEALTHY
DIET WITH DIGNITY. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE THANKS
FOR WHICH WILL ENSURE THAT
CHILDREN HAVE ACCESS TO THE
NUTRITION THEY NEED AT HOME AND
AT SCHOOL DURING MY TWENTY TWO
YEARS AT PRAC I'M TRACK WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN CHILDREN LOSE
ACCESS TO SCHOOL BREAKFASTS AND
LUNCHES THE IMPACT IS NOT
SURPRISING FOOD INSECURITY GOES
BAD AND CHILDREN GAIN MORE
WEIGHT. WHY DOES IT MATTER THAT
WE PUT CHILDREN AT RISK FOR
HUNGER BECAUSE HUNGER
NEGATIVELY IMPACTS CHILDREN'S
HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES SCHOOL
ATTENDANCE AND BEHAVIOR WHEN
THE PANDEMIC HIT CALIFORNIA TWO
POINT SIX MILLION CHILDREN WERE
ALREADY RECEIVING FREE OR
REDUCED PRICE SCHOOL LUNCH
WITHOUT WARNING AND IN SOME
CASES OVERNIGHT FAMILIES LOST
ACCESS TO SCHOOL MEALS THE
RESULT WAS WHAT WE SEE EVERY
SUMMER EVERY SCHOOL BREAK AND
LAST SPRING WAS EVEN LARGER
FAMILIES LOST JOBS AND WAGES
AND A PANDEMIC AMPLIFIED
ALREADY EXISTING RACIAL
INEQUITIES. COULDN'T SECURITY
FOR ALL HOUSEHOLDS WITH
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA ROSE
223% BUT IT INCREASED 236% FOR
BLACK HOUSEHOLDS WITH CHILDREN
AND 27% FOR LATIN ACT
HOUSEHOLDS WITH CHILDREN THE
BILL WOULD PROVIDE AN EBT CARD
TO LOW INCOME FAMILIES TO
PURCHASE FOOD. THAT THE EASIEST
AND SIMPLEST WAY TO PROVIDE
NUTRITION RESOURCES. WHEN
SCHOOLS ARE CLOSED- JOHNSON HAS
BEEN CHAU TO REDUCE FOOD IN.
AND CREWS NEED. THE BILL ON
WOULD ALLOW SCHOOL TO PROVIDE
DIRECT IN MY- TO ALL STUDENTS
AT NOTES. ENSURING THAT ALSO
ARE IN CLASS HEALTHY AND READY
TO LEARN. I ARGUED SUPPORT SB
SIX AND THAT OF THE. THANK YOU
AT THIS MOMENT WILL- OPEN IT UP
TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE SIX FOUR WILL BEGIN
WITH. THOSE THAT ARE HERE TO-
BY PUBLIC COMMENT AND FROM
FORTY TWO ZERO THREE. SEE NON
MOVING ON TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SEE NON WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
OPEN UP THE TELEPHONE LINE. THE
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES. AND CALL THE
SERVER FOR WITNESSES INDIVIDUAL
ARE IN. OKAY SORRY ABOUT THAT
NO PROBLEM. IF YOU ARE IN
PROPORTION SB THREE SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AND
WE DO HAVE ABOUT A TWENTY FIVE
IN Q. RIGHT NOW SO I WILL GO
AHEAD AND START WITH MY NUMBER
TWO ZERO NINE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON I KNOW I'VE
FOUGHT A MOLE WITH CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION. IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER WE ARE A
WE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO
ZERO THREE TWO HUNDRED AND
THREE PEOPLE HAD. THIS IS
TIFFANY MARC ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTER FOR FOOD SAFETY AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO ALL
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS
IS KEVIN IN SCROLL OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER
ONE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON DONNA
CALLING ON BEHALF OF COUNCIL
FOR A STRONG AMERICA AND READY
NATION AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
WE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON JUSTIN RAZA ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER ROOTS OF CHANGE
CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM AND PESTICIDE ACTION
NETWORK IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITH A LOCAL I.
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHRIS TO RESPONSIBLE LECTURES
ON LAW AND POVERTY WILL
PROBABLY BE SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO PLEASE CALL HADN'T.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS ACTUALLY
JEDNAK THE SCHOOL AND SUMMER
MEALS SPECIALIST AT THE SAN
DIEGO HUNGER COALITION CALLING
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MY NUMBER TWO TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
TERM MEMBERS OF ST NOT SURE
WHAT THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY NUMBER
TWO TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THAT ONE HAS DROPPED WILL VOTED
BLIND CHIU FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ASSEMBLY ROSENBERGER
WITH S. YEAH YOU CALIFORNIANS
TRUMP SUPPORT. THANK YOU MY
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KAREN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THIS IS AMANDA MAY SHASTA
HUNGER FREE KIDS MANAGER FROM A
HUNGER COALITION I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF OUR FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS TO THINK
IT'LL COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON REBECCA
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MY NUMBER TWO SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON EARLY
HUNDRED ON WITH WIDENING GROUP
ON BEHALF OF NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU BYE NUMBER TWO THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SURE
MEMBERS THIS IS ANDREW SHANE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF FOOD BANKS AND STRONG
SUPPORT AND A PERSONAL THANKS
IN THE CHAIR FOR ALL YOU DO YOU
TO FIGHT CHILD HUNGER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MY NUMBER TWO
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRS
SENATORS JEFF MARTIN WITH
BEATING SAN DIEGO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SIXTY FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY NUMBER
ONE EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON AT THE HELP
BRING WITH THE CENTER FOR ECO
LITERACY AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MY NUMBER ONE FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
AT HOWARD ON BEHALF OF THE
OFFICE OF CAT TAYLOR IN ON
BEHALF OF MY SOUL WOULD
NORMALLY BENEFITTED FROM THE
OCEAN ABOUT ONE PARTICULAR
PATIENT SCHOOL LUNCHES CHILD
RESPECTFULLY URGE ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU MY NUMBER TWO FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MICHAEL
RIDE AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS COUNTY OF
SANTA CLARA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MY NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS RACHEL MONACO
REPRESENTING SECOND HARVESTED
SILICON VALLEY STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND LINE NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. J.
THAT LINE HAS DROPPED OUT WE
WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
THEN OTHER IMPORTANT. AND WE
HAVE MY NUMBER ONE EIGHT SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
NATALIE CABLE FROM CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA BANK CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT SB THREE SIXTY
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
HAVE A LINE NUMBER ONE SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SUBRAMANIAN I'M WITH THE
CHILDREN. ONE MOMENT SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WE GO TO LINE NUMBER
TWO FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS LED
DAVIDSON REPRESENTING THE SAN
FRANCISCO MARIN FOOD BANK WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MY NUMBER. ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN. I CAN BARELY SACRAMENTO
COULD THINK OF THEM AS SERVICES
CALLING TRUMP SB. THREE SIXTY
FOUR. THANK YOU HAVE A LINE
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS CAROL FROM THE BANK
COALITION OF SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTY CALLING AN UNWAVERING
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU. AND WE'RE
GOING TO LINE UP TO SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS ERIC
FALL CALPERS THE LOS ANGELES
REGIONAL FOOD BANK CALLING IN%
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ARE GOING TO LINE NUMBER
TWO EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON PATRICIA
STURDIVANT ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF JEWISH
WOMEN SACRAMENTO SECTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU WE
HAVE ABOUT THREE IN THE QUEUE
STILL WE ARE GOING TO TWO
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON- UNDER A PERRY
REPRESENTING NO KID HUNGRY WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SIXTY FOUR WE THANK
SENATORS CAN EVER BRING IN A
STEP FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WE HAVE A NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JAMIE MORGAN
WITH THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
SB THREE SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THE LAST ONE
COMES FROM A LINE UP TO NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON EITHER COME INTO ON
ON BEHALF OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK IN STRONG
SUPPORTER SB THREE SIX FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND THERE
ARE NO OTHER THANK YOU OKAY.
OKAY THANK YOU HAVEN'T HEARD
FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WILL MOVE
ON TO LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WE DON'T HAVE ANY-
AND WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION- WILL BEGIN WITH
FORTY TWO OR THREE. SEE NON
MOVING ON TO TWENTY FORTY.
THREE NINE WILL BE NON TO THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT LINE
IN OPPOSITION. BOB MURRAY
PLEASE OPEN A ARE IN. OKAY I
APOLOGIZE. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AND I DO NOT SEE ANYBODY
QUEUING UP FOR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ARE I JUST WANTED.
STATE THAT THIS IS A DO YOU
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD IT'S- IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S YOU KNOW
DESPERATELY NEED INSTRUCTIONAL
TIME WHEN- DURING A PANDEMIC
INTERNIST EMERGENCY. BUT REALLY
ALL CHILDREN SHOULD HAVE ACCESS
TO. FOOD AND BE FOOD SECURE SO
I REALLY WANTED IT THANK YOU
FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY HEART FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
BEING. A CHAMPION ON THIS AND-
AND THEN I'LL JUST BRING IT
BACK TO- COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
REGARDING THIS BILL. BUT NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- WOULD BE
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL AT THE
PROPER TIME. THANK YOU CENTER
CORTESE- THERE IS A MOTION
WHAT'S OUR SENATORS CAN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU-
THE- WELL ONE THING I LEARNED
TODAY WHICH I FORGOT TO NOTE MY
OPENING. IS THAT I THINK SO.
THIS IS A RELEVANT TO TODAY BUT
I THINK SOME OF US MAY HAVE
BEEN FOLLOWING THE NEWS THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
STARTED TO TALK A LOT ABOUT-
THAT UNIVERSAL SCHOOL MEALS A
FREE MEAL SHOULD BE PART OF
SCHOOLS. BUT TODAY THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE
ANNOUNCED THAT IT WAS EXTENDING
WHAT'S CALLED THE SEAMLESS
SUMMER OPTION. FOR THIS COMING
SUMMER AND WHAT THAT IS THE
FEDERAL. SUMMER SCHOOL SUMMER
LUNCH PROGRAM IS AVAILABLE TO
ALL SIX KIDS IT IS NOT MEANS
TESTED SO WE NOW HAVE THE
OPTION TO DO THIS WITHOUT
STATUTE FOR THIS SUMMER- SO
THAT IS GREAT. AND IF WE ARE
SUCCESSFUL IN WE ENACT SB THREE
SIXTY FOUR THEN WOULD PUT
CALIFORNIA IN THE DIFFERENT WE
WOULD BE THE FIRST STATE TO
REALLY ENACT STATUTES LIKE THIS
BUT IT IS A TREND THAT I THINK
WE SEE NOW BEING TALKED ABOUT.
AND MOVED BY FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND OTHER STATES AND THEN
FINALLY. HAS SOME OF THE
WITNESSES MENTIONED- A KEY
ELEMENT OF THE BILL IS ALSO
THIS BETTER OUT OF SCHOOL TIME
NUTRITION PROGRAM CALLED BOOST.
WHICH IS MODELED AFTER THE
PANDEMIC EBT PROGRAM THAT IS
EXISTED IN THIS LAST. YEAR
WHICH ALLOWS FOR WHEN A SCHOOL
IS CLOSED SO LET'S H. DURING
THE VACATION TIME OR DURING
BECAUSE OF AN EMERGENCY OR
DISASTER PUBLIC HEALTH
CIRCUMSTANCE LIKE WE FACED.
BACK TO SCHOOL COULD PROVIDE
ANY BT CARD TO THE FAMILIES TO
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE PROVIDE
MEALS FOR THE SHOW THAT WE DO
NOT HAVE HUNGRY- STUDENTS. SO
WITH THAT I APPRECIATE THE-
CALL INS AND- YOUR COMMENTS
CHAIR IN WITHOUT A HOUSE FOR
YOU I VOTE ON SB THREE SIXTY
FOUR. THANK YOU. TO CONSULTANT
HE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
THREE SIXTY FOR THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED BUT FIRST BE RE
REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HER TADO HI FOR
TARO I JONES. COURTESY OF THE
CORTESE ARE A COMMON MARKER PAN.
AB WE WILL PLACE THIS BILL ON
HOLD TO ALLOW OTHER MEMBERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER. AT THIS MOMENT WE WILL
TAKE UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR. A
CONSULTANT CAN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SB FOUR NINE SEVEN BY THE MON
SB FIVE FOUR NINE JONES AND SB
SIX FOUR EIGHT HER TADO HI ADAM
BY HER TADO I'D JONES. CORTESE
BY PARTISI I'D COME LONGER PAN.
CONSENT ITEMS ARE ON CALL AND
WE WILL ALLOW OTHERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON THIS.
AT
THIS MOMENT WE WILL WAIT A FEW
MINUTES JUST TO ARM. HELLO BE A
NEXT AUTHORED TO. JOIN US. BEAR
WITH US. NEITHER. SURE SURE.
UHHUH UHHUH.
WE HAVE THREE
AUTHORS AND YOUR OLD MOLD A
CONTINUE TO GO OUT AND FIGHT
ORDER MOLD AT GO UP NEXT WITH
AGENDA ITEM FIVE WHICH IS A
CENTER LEFT LAYERED WITH YOUR
PRESENT SB FIVE ONE EIGHT AND
CENTER LOW LAYERED. COMFORT NOT
SEDATED IT PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR.
SORRY JUST RAN UP A BUNCH OF
FLIGHTS OF STAIRS- JUST GOOD
AFTERNOON AND I'M PRESENTING
SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTEEN WHICH
DEALS WITH SERVICES AND SELF
DETERMINATION FOR PERSONS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. THE
STATE PROGRAM FOR PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES WAS
RAMPED UP IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES IN PART. BY THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JERRY WALL THE
WHOSE SON WORKED WITH THE TWO
OF US- CENTERED AROUND
RESIDENTIAL STATE HOSPITALS AND
LOCAL SERVICES DELIVERED
THROUGH NEWLY ESTABLISHED
REGIONAL CENTERS. OVER THE LAST
DECADE TO STATE HOSPITALS HAVE
BEEN PHASED OUT. AND SERVICES
ARE DELIVERED ALMOST ENTIRELY
THROUGH LOCAL PROGRAMS FOR THE
STATE TO STRUGGLE TO ADEQUATELY
FUND LOCAL SERVICES. ENSURE
THAT THERE ARE ADEQUATE
SERVICES AT THAT LEVEL. IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN SENATOR BILL
EMERSON AUTHORED SENATE BILL
FOR SIXTY EIGHT WHICH ALLOWED
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF A STATE
WIDE SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM.
THE SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM
IS BASED ON SUCCESSFUL MULTI
YEAR SELF DETERMINATION PILOT
PROJECTS WHICH GAVE INDIVIDUALS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
AUTHENTIC PERSON CENTERED
PLANNING CHOICE AND CONTROL
OVER THEIR SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS. IN ADDITION TO BETTER
OUTCOMES. WITH POTENTIAL LONG
TERM COST SAVINGS THERE BEEN
DELAYS EVER SINCE TEN FIRST AND
GETTING A FEDERAL WAIVER FOR
THIS NEW OUGHT TO BE
IMPLEMENTED AND NOW FOR THREE
YEARS AFTER THE WAIVER JUST A
FRACTION OF THE ELIGIBLE
FAMILIES HAVE DEVELOP SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM. IT IS
BEEN MADE EVEN HARDER DURING
THE LAST YEAR TO THE PANDEMIC.
BUT THERE WAS SLOW
IMPLEMENTATION EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC. SENATE BILL FIVE
EIGHTEEN WILL REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES TO ESTABLISH AN OFFICE
OF THE SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM OMBUDSPERSON. AN
INDEPENDENT AND AUTONOMOUS
ENTITY WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT TO
AMONG OTHER THINGS ASSIST SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM.
PARTICIPANTS OVERCOME ANY
BARRIERS TO FULL PARTICIPATION
AND INCLUSION. THE OMBUDSPERSON
WILL WORK TO ADDRESS RACIAL AND
ETHNIC DISPARITIES PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INNOVATION
AND INCREASE PARTICIPANTS
CHOICE AND FLEXIBILITY. IT WILL
EQUIP THE OMBUDSPERSON TO
FACILITATE APPROPRIATE
TRAININGS. FOR SERVICE
COORDINATORS WITHIN THE
REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM AND TO
WORK WITH PARTICIPANTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES TO OBTAIN THE
PERSON SERVICES AND SUPPORT
THEY DESERVE. I'VE BEEN WORKING
SINCE I GOT HERE. THE MOST
RECENT TIME BUT TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO EXPEDITE THIS
PROCESS ALL THE CONVERSATIONS
AND ALL THE STAKEHOLDER
INTEREST HAS RESULTED IN THIS
BILL SO TODAY WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT THE SENATOR
BILL AMBERSONS THE ORIGINAL
AUTHOR OF SB FOUR SIXTY EIGHT
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN AND TIM JAN
BOARD MEMBER OF DISABILITY
VOICES UNITED AND SEVERAL OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING.
ABILITY CENTRAL PHILANTHROPY
BASED IN THE BAY AREA THANKS
FOR. ALLOWING ME 2% AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT. THANK
YOU MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR OUR LEAD
SUPPORT- NUMBER ONE SENATOR
SENATOR BILL ANDERSON. BLINDS
ARE OPEN. THANK YOU FOR
CALLING- INVITES JONES AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
HORNETS. ONE KONKURRENTEN
FORMER COLLEAGUE JOHN LAYERED
REDUCE BECAUSE THE PRODUCTS ARE
SIMPLY LEFT THE LEGISLATURE
OFFERING US SENATE BILL FIVE
ONE EIGHT THAT WILL HELP WILL
BE IMPLEMENTATION OF HEALTH.
COMBINATION IT'S HARD TO
BELIEVE THAT NEARLY EIGHT YEAR
HAVE PASSED SINCE BROWN CONSULT
TERMINATION- BOUGHT.
DETERMINATION WHAT PROMISED TO
KEEP WITH. A RECENT PROBABLY
RECEIVE THEM AND WHO PROVIDE
THEM. HOWEVER THE EARLY
PROMISES YET. WILL BE REALIZED
BECAUSE OF SUBSTANTIAL AND
BARRIERS TO COLE PART. AS OF
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY ONE ONLY
BECAUSE AND TWENTY FOUR
PARTICIPANTS EVENTUALLY
TRANSITION BEEN. MARTIN GREEN
CALL. IMPLEMENT OVER THE AND
HAVE- THE FIRST COULD OF AND
FAMILIES CRYING COULD. THIS
PROGRAM. CHANGING THE LAWS ONE
ACHIEVING TO IN CULTURE OTHER.
TO ME BROKE WORK. THE LEGAL
LINE HUNDRED IS QUITE ANOTHER.
I BELIEVE THAT CREATE AN IN THE
OFFICE HOPE TO TURN ON
SPOKESMAN WATER. IN THE TO
ADVOCATE TO HELP MOVE THEM
FORWARD IN THIS SO TERMINATION
PROGRAM. WE WILL ALSO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT IN SORRY POWERS TO
BREAK DOWN WHICH. TEACHERS OF
THE SENATE BILL. ARE ALSO
IMPORTANT SUCH AS RICK TRAINS
TO WHO INTERNAL CENTER STAFF.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
LET AND SENATE SENDING SOME
OTHER COULD BE CONCERNING LINES
INQUIRE AND WILL OF THE ROOF-
REGIONAL CENTERS I SUPPORT
SENATE BILL. FIVE EIGHTEEN.
THANK SENATOR MERCED AND I
BELIEVE WE ARE HAVE- BIG
SUPPORT OF TWO ON THE CALL.
YEAH PLEASE PLAY MY NAME IS TO
CHEN I'M HERE TODAY TO TELL IN
OF THE B. ONE EIGHT. IT IS MY-
I MADE FORTY YEAR OLD KOREAN
AMERICAN MAN WHO HAS CEREBRAL
PALSY. I AM USING A
COMMUNICATION DEVICE AT THE
BASE OF MY WHEELCHAIR BY TYPING
WITH MY TONGUE. MY PRONOUNS ARE
HE AND HIM BUT IF YOU ASK MY
FRIENDS THEY HAVE OTHER
PRONOUNS FOR ME THAT ARE NOT
APPROPRIATE TO MENTION IN A
SENATE HEARING. I AM ON THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF
DISABILITY VOICES UNITED STATES
WIDE ORGANIZATION DIRECTED BY
AND FOR PEOPLE WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES. B. R.
COSPONSORING SB FIVE ONE EIGHT
ALONG WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA. THIS WEEKEND WE
HELD A VIRTUAL SELF
DETERMINATION CONFERENCE WITH
ONE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
PEOPLE SIGNED UP. THERE WAS SO
MUCH EXCITEMENT ABOUT THE STATE
WIDE ROLL OUT IN JUNE AND YOU
MUCH DISCUSSION ABOUT BREAKING
DOWN THE BARRIERS THAT SELF
ADVOCATES AND FAMILIES HAVE
FACED. I WAS SELECTED TO GO
INTO THE SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM IN NOVEMBER TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN BUT IT'S BEEN
VERY DIFFICULT FOR ME TO GET
STARTED. FROM THE BEGINNING BY
REGIONAL CENTER HAS NOT BEEN
SUPPORTIVE. SERVICE CO
ORDINATOR ACTUALLY SENT ME AN
EMAIL SAYING THE PROGRAM IS NOT
RIGHT FOR ME. A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE BEING TOLD BY REGIONAL
CENTERS THAT SELF DETERMINATION
IS TOO HARD. HE HEARD THIS
REPEATEDLY AT THE CONFERENCE
PARTICULARLY FROM PEOPLE OF
COLOR. PEOPLE WANT TO GO INTO
THE STP BUT THE BARRIERS ARE SO
CLEAR AND PROFOUND. IF YOU ASK
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WE'LL
HEAR CONSISTENT THEMES ABOUT
THE PROBLEMS WE FACE BECAUSE OF
REGIONAL CENTER RESISTANCE I
BUCKLE. THERE IS A REPORT FROM
THE STATE WIDE SELF
DETERMINATION ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THAT REALLY GOES INTO
DETAIL WITH RECOMMENDATIONS
MOST OF WHICH HAVE NEVER BEEN
IMPLEMENTED. LET ME GIVE YOU A
COUPLE OF EXAMPLES OF THE
BARRIERS. THE FIRST IS THAT IT
HAS TAKEN SO DARN LONG FOR GPS
TO IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM. WE
ARE ALMOST AT EIGHT YEARS. IT
REALLY LOST MOMENTUM FOR THE
PROGRAM. BUT THE ENERGY HAS
RETURNED IN ANTICIPATION OF THE
STATE WIDE ROLL OUT IN JUNE.
ANOTHER MAJOR BARRIER FACT
WHILE PARTICIPANTS AND FAMILIES
HAVE TO GO TO AN OVERLY
COMPLICATED ORIENTATION
REGIONAL CENTER STAFF ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO HAVE ANY TRAINING.
WE HEAR THAT MANY SERVICE CO
ORDINATORS DON'T INTERSTELLAR
IN THE PROGRAM KEEPING THEIR
CLIENTS FROM MOVING FORWARD. SB
FIVE ONE EIGHT WILL REMEDY THAT
SITUATION BY REQUIRING ONLY
GENERAL CENTER STAFF GET
TRAINING ON THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM. THE BILL
ALSO REQUIRES REGIONAL CENTERS
TO INFORM ALL OF THEIR CLIENTS
ABOUT THE PROGRAM. SB FIVE ONE
EIGHT DOES MUCH MORE THAN THAT.
IT CREATES THE OFFICE OF THE
OMBUDSPERSON FOR THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM WHO WOULD
INVESTIGATE THE BARRIERS WE ARE
FACING AND HELP US TO OVERCOME
THAT. BEYOND BUDGET PERSON WILL
BE CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS OF
THE PROGRAM. WE ARE HOPING THAT
SB FIVE ONE EIGHT AS IT MOVES
THROUGH THE SENATE WILL ENSURE
THE INDEPENDENCE OF THE
OMBUDSPERSON OFFICE AND
CONTAINER DIVISIONAL
PROVISIONS. SUCH AS ADDING
CLEAR TIMELINES FOR REGIONAL
CENTERS. IT HAS BEEN A TOUGH
ROAD. BUT AS WITH OTHER CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT FREEDOM IS
ALWAYS WORTH IT. I DON'T SEE
THE SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM
WAS JUST A DIFFERENT WAY TO
RECEIVE SERVICES. I SEE HAVING
CHOICE AND CONTROL OVER ONE'S
LIFE AS A BASIC CIVIL AND HUMAN
RIGHT. THAT IS WHY WE NEED THE
SELF DETERMINATION PROGRAM TO
SUCCEED AND SB FIVE ONE EIGHT
WILL HELP US TO GET THERE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TEMPER
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY- AT THIS
MOMENT I WANT TO MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
ONE EIGHT DOUBLE BEGIN WITH
ROOM FOR. FORTY TWO ZERO THREE.
C. NINE MOVING ON TO ROUTE
TWENTY FORTY. SEEN ON THERE- WE
WILL BE MOVING ON TO THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT LINE
IN SUPPORT OF. SB. FIVE ONE
EIGHT. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE ONE EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AND W HAVE
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE PUBLIC
COMMENTS. AND I WILL GO TO THE
LINE UP TO SIXTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS DR
HARVEY LATE THEN THE MY WIFE
CONNIE LATE. ONE OF BANKS
SENATORS WHERE MUCH FOR DOING
THIS WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS WHAT BUSINESSES CIVIL
RIGHTS THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
REMINDER TO OUR OUR CALLERS
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION AND- ON
THIS BILL. WE WILL BORDERLINE
OF TWO THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WE'RE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR SENATE BILL FIVE ONE
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY
NUMBER ONE NINETY SEVEN. HELLO
AMY YES. OKAY MY NAME IS TONY
DEADLINE I'M PART OF THE
ORGANIZATION OF ANY PATIENT
INTO A COMMUNITY COLLABORATIVE
AND I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
FIVE POINT EIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE GO TO LINE UP TO
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS VALERIE COULD
NOT. AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CITIZENS OF SANTA CLARA COUNTY
I WANT TO THANK SENATE DELAYED
FOR THE BETTER I AM IN SUPPORT
SENATE BILL FIVE MONEY. THANK
YOU. AMADOR LINE NUMBER THREE
OH FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE
OH FIVE. EMILY I AM SORRY. I
SUPPORT THE H. B. ONE EIGHT.
THANK YOU. WE GOT A LINE NUMBER
TWO SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWO SEVEN SIX. SEVENTY SIX A
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY NUMBER
BLANCA COBB FONG I'M HERE FOR
YOU IF. THANKS FOR YOUR TRIP.
YES YES. WHEN WE GO TO THE LINE
OF THREE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MANSUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
FERNANDO GOMEZ ON BEHALF OF MY
FAMILY. AND THE INTEGRATED
COMMUNITY COLLABORATIVE
REPRESENTING TWELVE HUNDRED
FAMILIES WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB FIVE ONE EIGHT
THANK. THANK YOU. THEN WE GO TO
LINE NUMBER THREE FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OKAY WE WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER THREE ONE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO NOT ME
REFRESH HERE. I APOLOGIZE.
RECOUP YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR YOU YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION A POSITION ON
THE BILL. YOUR UNIT IN ME. YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU. CAN YOU PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION A
POSITION. OKAY MY NAME IS TO
RELY ON MY PROPOSED IT FOR YOU
SB. FIVE ONE EIGHT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. A RECORD A LINE
NUMBER TWO THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. OKAY WE WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER THREE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
LAUREN ABUNDANCE I STRONGLY
SUPPORT. FIVE ONE EIGHT EIGHT
ONE NIGHT HOW ABOUT A
DISABILITY TILE JOB AND I
STRONG SUPPORTER THANK YOU. AND
WE WILL GO TO MY NUMBER THREE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE TWENTY ONE YOUR MIND. IS
ME- HI MY NAME IS LINDA CHAN
AROUND. I'M A PARENT OF THE
ADULT DAUGHTER WITH. IN SELF
DETERMINATION AND I THINK
SENATORS LAYERED. FOR SENATE
BILL FIVE EIGHTEEN AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WELL I
NUMBER THREE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES HI MY NAME ISN'T
DELICA VIA I AM THE MOTHER OF A
DOWN SYNDROME LITTLE GIRL AND
THANK YOU SENATOR AIRED AND I
SUPPORT SB FIVE ONE EIGHT.
THANK THANK YOU. A LITTLE LINE
NUMBER THREE OH SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS SUE GAVIN I
AM THE PARENT OF A REGIONAL
CENTER CLIENT. THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYER I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF BY TWENTY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WELL WE WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER THREE SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M YOU. SO
MUCH I AM A STARK BEFORE OF THE
SB. FIVE SEVENTEEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE WILL BORDERLINE
NUMBER THREE TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES FROM THE
INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE I THINK BEING
THAT I. OR AND FOR SB EIGHT BY
ONE THANK YOU. HEY WE WILL
LOCAL I. NUMBER TWO TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL I NUMBER
TWO TWENTY NINE. I HAD FOR.
DOUBLE BELT. DOT APART THE IT
FIVE EIGHT THE BILL THANK YOU.
WE GO TO LINE NUMBER TWO NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JOSE LARA I'M A FATHER TO
SPECIAL NEEDS. CHILDREN AND
STRONG SUPPORTER OF SB. FIVE
EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU WITHOUT A
LINE NUMBER TWO SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS HUGO
PINEDA ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA
WITH INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE. SPECIAL THANKS
TO SENATOR MERDE AND I'M AT THE
BAR OF SB FIVE ONE EIGHT. YOU
ARE LINE NUMBER THREE FORTY TWO.
THREE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LOCAL I. NUMBER TWO
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MORAN AND
I'M A MOTHER OF AN ELEVEN YEAR
OLD SON WITH THEM THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYERED AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB FIVE EIGHTEEN. SHE
IT WAS ABOUT A LINE OVER ONE
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS MELISSA METEORITE AM
STARK I'M A PARENT OF A CHILD
AT WESTSIDE REGIONAL CLAMOR.
AND INSURE LOCKBOURNE. SB FIVE
THANKS FOR. THANK YOU WE HAVE
ONE NUMBER ONE FORTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
FERNANDO PACHECO AND I AM THE
FATHER OF A SON WHO FINALLY GOT
INTO THE SELF DETERMINATION AND
I WHOLEHEARTEDLY. SUPPORT SB
FIVE ONE EIGHT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THEY ONLY HAVE ONE NUMBER
THREE THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
GOMEZ AND I AM A PARENT OF A
CHILD- DOWN SYNDROME BUT I'M
ALSO THE DIRECTOR OF THE
INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE. THANK YOU I
THANK YOU SENATOR. I'M WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT AS THE FIVE
ONE EIGHT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
WITH A LINE NUMBER THREE THIRTY
FOUR. HI MY NAME IS TOMMY
PARMESAN A PARENT OF AN
AUTISTIC YOUNG MAN IN THE
REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM I WANT
TO THANK SENATOR LAYERED AND AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
ONE EIGHT. THANK YOU. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWO TWENTY SIX GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KIDADA
MEDINA PARENT ADVOCATE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I AM IN
STRONG STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL FIVE ONE EIGHT AND I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU THE SENATE
SENATOR. AND BENNIFER MHM AND
YOUR THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
NUMBER TO TWENTY SIX GO AHEAD.
BY NUMBER TWO TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO SO I HAD.
HI MY NAME IS TAMMY BRADLEY I'M
A SELF ADVOCATE AND I WANT TO
THANK SENATOR LAYER AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU MY NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE GO TO CLIMB NUMBER TWO
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. OKAY
HI MY NAME IS NOT AVAILABLE
MIGHT ACTION IN A. M. AB ONE OF.
NDT YOU IMPACTED DARK IN A AND
SHE COULD THINK SENATOR LARRY
AND- ACCORDING TO OUR- AND
HELLO I'M SORRY. I DON'T FOR
THE EIGHTY ONE EIGHT. THANK YOU.
THE NEXT LINE IS TWO FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER TWO
FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY WE WILL GO TO THE NEXT
LINE OF THE THREE FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALONE THREE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO YES WE ALL HAVE YOU
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
PLEASE. THANK THE BANK FOR. YES
WE'RE WE'RE TAKING OUR-
TESTIMONY HERE ON A IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE ONE EIGHT CAN YOU
SEE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION A
POSITION ON THE BILL.
CONTAMINATION IF AFFECT EMPIRE
OKAY INTEGRATED CLINICAL DAWLAT
CANNELLA THAT DANIEL SOMETHING
UP BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND I'M
A BIG SUPPORTER. IS SB. FIVE
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU FOR. THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
THREE FORTY NINE GO AHEAD. BY
NUMBER THREE FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WE WILL GO TO THE
LINE UP TO SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY NUMBER TWO SIXTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CHRIS. I
AM A PARENT OF A CHILD WITH
AUTISM AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
AT. FIVE ONE EIGHT. AMICALE I
NUMBER THREE SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WANT TO LEARN
MORE THAN ONE MOBILE MISSINS
JOHNSON ON THE MOTHER OF THE
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD BOB WHICH
MARKED. I AM A STRONG SUPPORTER
OF BILL FIVE ONE EIGHT. THANK
YOU WOULD GO TO THE LINE OF
THREE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JOHN FRANCIS I AM A-
FAMILY MEMBER TO MY NEPHEW WHO
HAS SIGNIFICANT SPECIAL NEEDS.
I WANT TO THANK SANDERS CENTER
LAYERED FOR A SB. FIVE ONE
EIGHT AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
BECAUSE THIS JUST MAKES SENSE
FOR FOLKS THAT ARE ARE
STRUGGLING OUT. THANK YOU I
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY NUMBER THREE
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS JUDY MARC I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF DISABILITY VOICES
UNITED AND I WANT TO THANK
CENTER WHERE DID YOU STAFF AS A
CO SPONSOR. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE INCREDIBLE
SUPPORT THAT YOU'VE GIVEN AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE SENATOR. YOU GET THIS BILL
PASSED THANK YOU. I'D WANT TO
REMIND THE COLORS THAT ARE-
WAITING OUTSIDE TO PUT UP.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION ONLY
THANK YOU. WE RECORDED LINE
NUMBER THREE NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY NUMBER TWO NINETY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I DIDN'T
HEAR ME YES WE CAN. I STATION I
AM HERE TO SUPPORT ANOTHER
ISLAMIC AND I'LL ME FIVE POINT.
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU. NAME
WITHOUT A LINE NUMBER THREE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
HI MY NAME IS MARTIN LEITNER.
RIGHT NOW BUT CHILD WITH AUTISM
I STRONGLY SUPPORTED THE PARTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND WE GO
TO LINE NUMBER TWO THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT LINE HAS
DROPPED WE WILL BORDERLINE
THREE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO. LAST NAME
ORGANIZATION SESSION. HI MY
NAME IS PETER HERNANDEZ AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB FIVE EIGHT
AND I'M FROM THE GROUP ID THANK
YOU. HEY WE RECORDER LINE
NUMBER TWO FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS BY THE LEAD GROUP I AM
A MOTHER TO A CHILD WITH AUTISM
I AM ALSO IN THE GROUP- AT WITH
ICC AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
FIVE ONE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
I WOULD GO TO MY NUMBER THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION PLEASE.
HI MY NAME IS NADIA LEBRON MOST
AND I'M- PERRIN TO OUR TWENTY
TWO YEAR OLD WHO HAS ON THEM
AND I MEAN STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THE SB. FIVE ONE EIGHT THANK
YOU. OKAY WE GO TO LINE NUMBER
THREE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS THE
WESTMINSTER KENNEL VOTER
TURNOUT WOULD THINK I WOULD BE
COURT AS THE FIVE EIGHTEEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HOWEVER
LINE NUMBER TWO FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO FIFTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE WILL MOVE
ON TO LINE NUMBER THREE EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH HELLO
THERE MY MEDICAL CONVENIENCE I
AM FROM AUSTRALIA. I SUPPORT
THAT SB FIVE ONE EIGHT. THANK
YOU. THERE WE GO TO LINE NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DOWN SYNDROME IRANIAN
INDEPENDENTLY YEAH I DON'T KNOW.
ONE OF. I'M NOT. EIGHT THANK
YOU. AND THEN WE GO THROUGH THE
LINE NUMBER WE HAVE THE LINES
GIVEN HERE THAT TO MARIN Q. IT
LOOKS LIKE HERE AND WE'RE JUST
WAITING FOR THE LINE NUMBERS.
BY NUMBER THREE NINETY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS JENNY.
LAND CLEARING UP TO
INEXPERIENCE- LOOKING TO
TESTIFY IN TO SB FIVE ONE EIGHT
V. TELEPHONE PLEASE REMEMBER
TO. STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION A POSITION ONLY
AND MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINES INDIVIDUALLY. MORE
MODERATOR MY NUMBER FOUR OH
THREE I'M SORRY FOUR OH THREE
LINE IS OPEN- WHEN I SAID THAT
THE NUMBER THIRTY NOTHING NOT
MOTHER ADVOCATE I. HE I'M
STRONG BY EIGHTEEN. OKAY SIX
THANK YOU WARREN ALL WORD. TO-
CALLS AT THIS MOMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. ONE. MY WE
HAVEN'T CALL OF FIVE ONE EIGHT
PLEASE. ONE EIGHT ZERO. AND I
DO NOT SHOWING IN YOUR FOR A-
THANK YOU. I WILL BRING THE
CONVERSATION TO A COMMITTEE
MEMBER AND JOB WE SEE I HAVE
CENTER PAN AND CERTAINLY-
CENTER PLANT FREE TO BE THANK
YOU AND EARLIER AND I THINK YOU
FOR BRINGING SB FIVE ONE EIGHT
I KNOW THAT- WHEN WE- HEARD THE-
WHAT WE TALK ABOUT- THE- THE-
THE DEVELOPER OF AND NOW
SUSPECTS OF WE TALK ABOUT SORT
DRUM IN THE LOW TAKE UP FOR SO
THIS HELP. PEOPLE ENGAGE OUT
ALSO JUST MAKE NOTE THAT- WELL
I KNOW THAT THE I THINK BILL TO
PROTECT IS ABOUT- BUT- BUT IT'S
BEEN RELATE TO THIS THIS. TO
PRO. THAT- THERE MIGHT BE OTHER-
PLACES IN- DEVELOPMENTS. WELL
CERTAIN WE HAVE MANY VERY FOR
PEOPLE PROVIDING SERVICES WHERE
AND- MAY BE USEFUL. AS WELL.
WAS MOVING THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE NUMEROUS
CONVERSATIONS I HAD WITH THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY. ON SELF
DETERMINATION- AND WANTING TO
SEE THAT. EARLY PASS I ALSO
KNOW THAT OUR TRADITIONAL
REGIONAL CENTER SYSTEM REALLY
DOESN'T PROVIDE FOR THE
FLEXIBILITY AND THE AUTHORITY
THAT SELF DETERMINATION DOES I
TO- AGREE WITH DOCTOR PAN THAT
THE FACT THAT WE ONLY HAVE FIVE
HUNDRED FOLKS PARTICIPATING IN
THE PROGRAM IS PALTRY. TO SAY
THE LEAST ESPECIALLY
CONSIDERING THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF- FOLKS WITH
DISABILITIES WHO LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA. I WAS WONDERING- AS
IT RELATES TO THE OMBUDSMAN.
THE BILL SAYS THAT THE
OMBUDSMAN WOULD BE IN DDS AND I
WAS WONDERING IF THERE WAS ANY
THOUGHT TO HAVING IT OUTSIDE OF
DDS SINCE DDS IS THE ENTITY
THAT IT WOULD BE MONITORING.
OKAY MADAM CHAIR I GUESS TO THE
CHAIR PLEASE BUT- YES. WE GAVE
A LOT OF THOUGHT TO THIS AND
TRIED TO. DO IT SO IT'S
INDEPENDENT WITH IN THERE IS
THE BEST PLACE TO PUT IT IN.
OUR BE HONEST WE NEED TO GET
THIS BILL SIGNED AS WELL AND SO
I THINK TRYING TO DO IT
INDEPENDENTLY WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT WAS OUR BEST
STRATEGY. WHY WOULD I JUST
ENCOURAGE US TO BE AS BOLD AS
POSSIBLE WHEN WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT THE- THE DD COMMUNITY
BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN
FORGOTTEN- FOR MANY MANY
LEGISLATIVE CYCLES- AND THEY
ARE HURTING SO I HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING AND- WE ENCOURAGE
US SAYS GET THAT GRASS OF LEE
BOLD- IN FIGURING OUT HOW TO.
PROVIDE THE KIND OF
INDEPENDENCE AND- AUTHORITY
THAT I THINK WOULD BE REQUIRED
TO MAKE THIS SUCCESSFUL BUT I
WILL BE SUPPORTING AND I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL. THANK
YOU DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON SB FIVE
ONE EIGHT. NO OKAY CENTER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES FIRST LET
ME JUST- I KNOW THERE WERE A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT TESTIFIED IN
LET ME THANK THE MALL AND JUST
SAY THAT WHILE THEY THANK ME
THEY REALLY SHOULD BE THANKING.
THE FAMILIES AND EVERYBODY THAT
WORKS IN THIS FIELD BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE A LOT OF FOR HER
ROLE WE CAN ACTIONS AND WORK IS
GOING ON. AND TO THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE BY SENATOR ARE
CALM LONGER. THEY'RE GOING TO
SAY. GROUP ONE I WAS. YOUR
CHAIR IN MY PREVIOUS
INCARNATION. THE R. HOSPITALS
WERE BEING CLOSED DOWN. AND A
LOT OF THE PEOPLE IN THE
HOSPITALS WERE GOING TO LOCAL
SERVICES. AND AT THE TIME IT
WAS A CLICHE. THAT 80% OF THE
MONEY WENT 220% OF THE PEOPLE
IN THE SYSTEM. THAT AND THEN
20% OF THE MONEY WENT TO THE
REGIONAL LOCATIONS WHERE THERE
WERE EIGHTY PERCENT. AND WHEN
THE STATE CLOSE DOWN THE
HOSPITAL SENATE A LOT OF IT WAS
<c.blue>URING THE GREAT RECESSION. THE</c>
MONEY THAT WAS SO CALLED SAVED
BY THE HOSPITALS DID NOT MOVE
TO LOCAL SERVICES. AND SO. ARE
WHEN IT WAS MENTIONED THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE RIGHTEOUS.
ACTION THIS IS ALSO A BUDGET
ISSUE AS WELL AS MAKING THE
SELF DETERMINATION PLANTS WORK
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
HERE ABOUT THIS BILL. AND WE'RE
HERE ABOUT MAKING SELF
DETERMINATION WORK. AND IT IS
REALLY. A THING WE HAVE TO DO
BUT THERE ARE THINGS THAT NEED
TO BE DONE AND OTHER- FORMATS
AS WELL SO I APPRECIATE. THE
TIME HAS BEEN SPENT ON THIS AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR KNOWING
FROM. THANK YOU- AND AT THIS
MOMENT A COUPLE TO KEEP PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR PAN. SB FIVE ONE
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST. RE REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY HER TADO I HER TADO
I'D JONES JONES III CORTESE.
CORTEZ THE ICON MARKER HI COM
LONGER I'D PAN NIGHT AND I.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. THE VOTE IS FIVE ZERO
AND THE BILL IS OUT- UP NEXT WE
HAVE SENATOR RUBIO FOR A CHEN
HERE TO PRESENT ON THE AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB. FIVE THREE
SEVEN. WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN WHICH AIMS TO ADDRESS
EXISTING ISSUES WITH FAILURE TO
PROTECT LAWS AND TO CREATE A
CRITICAL WORKING GROUP TO
FURTHER ANALYZE TRACK THE DATA
AND MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ON
WAYS TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES COMMITTEE
MEMBERS VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ARE ALREADY DEALING
WITH TRAUMA ISOLATION AND
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL ABUSE THAT
THEY'VE ENTERED AND THEIR
RELATIONSHIPS WE CANNOT RE
TRAUMATIZE VICTIMS BY REMOVING
THEIR CHILDREN SOLELY ON THE
BASIS OF BEING VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR IN HER
COMMITTEE STAFF- AND ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WORKED AND
ENGAGED WITH ME ON THIS BILL I
WANT TO KNOW THAT I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY THAT HAVE BEEN
OFFERED. THE PROBLEM WE
CURRENTLY HAVE WHEN IT COMES TO
PHILLY TO PROTECT IS THE LACK
OF COMMUNICATION AND
COORDINATION WHEN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IS FOUND IN THE HOME
AS WELL AS A LACK OF SERVICES
WE PROVIDE. TO VICTIMS FACING
ABUSE. FAILURE TO PROTECT LAWS
ARE DESIGNED TO GUARD CHILDREN
FROM THE NEGATIVE EFFECTS OF
EXPENDABLES ARE TO
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE HOWEVER.
IN MANY CASES THESE LAWS ARE
CONTINUING TO PUT FAMILIES AND
VICTIMS AT A DISADVANTAGE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY'RE ALREADY
DEALING WITH TRAUMA. WE MUST
CONTINUE TO PUSH FORWARD
DISCUSSION AND FIGURE OUT HOW
TO ENSURE THAT CHILD WELFARE
AGENCIES WORK CLOSELY WITH
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO ADDRESS THE MANY
CHILDREN THAT ARE DYING. AT THE
HANDS OF ABUSERS. I KNOW THERE
ARE CONCERNS ABOUT SECTION
THREE HUNDRED AND THIS BILL AND
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT WE
WILL BE WORKING OUT IN
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES IN THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. BUT
ON BEHALF OF PEAKY A LITTLE BOY
WHO WAS FIVE YEARS OLD. AND MY
DISTRICT WHO DIED AT THE HANDS
OF HIS FATHER WHEN THE COURTS
FAILED TO LISTEN TO HIS MOTHER
AND ON BEHALF OF ALL OTHER
CHILDREN THAT HAVE BEEN
MURDERED OR PUT IN HARM'S WAY.
DUE TO THE FAILURE TO PROTECT
LOSS AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN. I
URGE AN IDOL THANK YOU. ON THE
PHONE TODAY IF I MAY I WANTED
TO DO SOME OF MY WITNESS AMINAH
MERIT ATTORNEY AT THE MERRITT
LAW CLINIC. AND A COMMUNITY FOR
PEACE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO IN YOUR
OFFICE FOR SPONSORING THIS BILL
AND HAVING YOU TESTIFIED TODAY
IN FAVOR OF SB FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN I BELIEVE I BEAR THE
QUALIFICATIONS TO TESTIFY
HAVING WORKED IN THE AREA OF
CHILD WELFARE AND JUVENILE
DEPENDENCY LAW. SINCE THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES RENDON
PROFESSOR LATER SENATOR NOW LA
SUPERVISOR SHEILA KEWELL KEWELL
SCHOOLED ME ON THIS AREA AND
PRACTICES AND THE PLIGHT OF
WOMEN AND CHILDREN THROUGH THE
EYES OF THE LAW WHILE I WAS A
STUDENT AT USC GOULD SCHOOL OF
BLACK. IN THE NINETIES I HAD
THE EXPERIENCE OF WORKING FOR
AN INSURANCE DEFENSE FIRM IN
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
REPRESENTING THEN DPSS LATER
DCFS IN CASES INVOLVING DEATH
OR INJURIES TO CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE AND THEN THE
NOTORIOUS MCLAREN HOLLOW LOS
ANGELENOS JUVENILE HALL IN EAST
LA. AND LATE. USE NEAR LAKE
CHRISTIAN. LATER BECAME AN
ATTORNEY AT SAC IT'S ADVOCATES
AND LATER CHILDREN LOS. AND
HAVE THAT AS COUNSEL COURT
APPOINTED AND PRIVATELY COUNCIL
FOR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN
SACRAMENTO YOLO PLASTER CONTRA
COSTA AND ALAMEDA COUNTY. I
TESTIFIED FOR THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION ON FOSTER CARE LED
BY SENATOR KAREN BASS WHICH I
BELIEVE HELPS THEM AND- WELFARE
AND INSTITUTIONS CODE SECTION
THREE SIXTY ONE POINT THREE THE
RELATIVE PLACEMENT PREFERENCE.
I ALSO WORK TO TEMPORARILY WITH
THE ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICE OF
THE COURTS THAT THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL CONDUCTING TITLE FOR E.
REVIEWS OF THE JUVENILE COURT.
IN SAN ANDREAS AND SANTA
BARBARA AND IMPERIAL COUNTY.
EAST THIRTY FIVE PLUS YEARS OF
WORK IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM HAVE GIVEN ME A
FIRSTHAND VIEW OF WHAT I
BELIEVE ARE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. FROM INTENSIFIED
SOCIAL SERVICES TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
DESPITE THE ENACTMENT OF
SECTION THREE HUNDRED POINT
FOUR IN MY EXPERIENCE SECTION
THREE HUNDRED BE KNOWN BY
PRACTITIONERS AS THE QUOTE
UNQUOTE CATCH ALL PHRASE.
ALLOWS SOCIAL SERVICES TO
ALLEGE THAT PARENTS QUOTE
ENGAGED IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND CLOSE THEIR BY FORMING THE
BASIS FOR A SUSTAINED CONDITION
WHEN CERTAIN CONDITIONS ARE
MET. CALLING A VICTIM SOMEONE
ENGAGED IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CHAU THE MISUNDERSTANDING OF
THE CYCLE OF VIOLENCE THE
TREATMENT OF PEOPLE IN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CASES ON THE GROUND
BECAUSE THIS FAMILY SEPARATION
WITHOUT REALLY ADDRESSING THE
TRAUMA TO THE FAMILY AS A
WHOLE. THE ALLEGATIONS OFTEN
SHOW A MISUNDERSTANDING OF THE
NATURE OF FAMILY VIOLENCE THE
CULTURE OF VIOLENCE AND THE
CYCLE OF VIOLENCE FROM A TRAUMA
INFORMED OPPRESSION LENDEDU
POINT. IT JUST STICKS WHICH CAN
BE FOUND AT CBS SAYS R. DOT
BERKELEY DOT EDU THE UC
BERKELEY WEBSITE. OUR FOSTER
CARE IN CALIFORNIA WE'LL SHOW
THAT YOU'RE- OUR CASES AND THE-
OF COLOR. AND IT IS COURT ALITY
OF THEM BY CAN AMONG THE-
RESPONSES FORGET THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ARE REAL PEOPLE WHO GO
TO COURT YOU NOT. REAL
SOLUTIONS TO THE PROBLEM IT
CHILDREN TRAUMATIZED BY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ARE RE
TRAUMATIZED BY FAMILY
SEPARATION THE VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ARE RE
TRAUMATIZED BY A SYSTEM THAT
TAKES AWAY SOME OF THEIR
SUPPORT SYSTEMS. IMPROVISATION
IMPROPER AGED FAMILIES ARE TOLD
TO GO TO FAMILY COURT WHICH HAS
NO COURT APPOINTED ATTORNEYS TO
GET RESTRAINING ORDERS FURTHER
SEPARATING CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES AND CAUSING ADDITIONAL
FINANCIAL THE FACT. I CAN CITE
THREE BRIEFCASE EXAMPLES SHOW
THE GROWTH UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ALLEGATIONS UNDER
SECTION THREE HUNDRED B. THREE
HUNDRED POINTS FOR OUR BLACK
BROWN LGBTQ ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDERS IMMIGRANTS AN
IMPOVERISHED COMMUNITY. ONE
CASE YOU'RE A WEDGE BETWEEN A
MOTHER AND DAUGHTER ARE MUCH
LONGER THAN THE STATUTORY TIME
FOR REUNIFICATION ANOTHER
CONTINUETO BE ABUSED AND
TRAFFICKED BY THE PERPETRATOR
AND I WOULD NOT BE SURPRISED IF
I LOOK IN THE RIGHT PLACE ON
THE INTERNET. I COULD PROBABLY
FIND BOTH THE MOTHER AND NOW
ADULT DAUGHTERS CONTINUING TO
BE TRAFFIC. BACK CASE WITH THE
FAILURE TO RENDON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ANOTHER CASE ALMOST
FINANCIALLY DESTROYED AN
EXTENDED IMMIGRANT FAMILIES WHO
EARN JUST OVER THE AMOUNT FOR
COURT APPOINTED COUNSEL THE
DAUGHTER HER HUSBAND AND CHILD
HAD YOU MOVED. FROM THE PARENTS
GRANDPARENTS HOME OVER SPEECHES
ALLEGATIONS THAT ALSO DERAILED
THEIR PLAN TO PURCHASE A HOUSE
THEY HAD TO BUY AN APARTMENT
AND FIND OTHER CHILD CARE
BECAUSE OF A SOUL ALLEGATION OF
FAMILY VIOLENCE IN THE FORM OF
A SPANKING. THE FINAL CASE. A
SINGLE FATHER IN THE BAY AREA
SQUARE ASKED GET EVERY.ORDER
IN THEM OF HIS TEAM BOYS WHEN
HE AND MORE HER TO BE A TO MAKE.
OUR VISITS AND REPLACE. WITH
THEM HE WAS TOLD THAT IF HE
DIDN'T DO SO THE BOYS COULD BE
REMOVED FROM HIM AND A
PETITIONS AND STAINED DUE TO
HIS NICKELBACK. MY EXPERIENCE
INFORMS ME THAT THE PROPOSAL SB
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN WILL BE A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
REQUIRING A CLOSE LOOK AT THESE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AND
EXAMINE WHAT WE DO TO. ADDRESS
OUR FOR FAMILIES WE ARE STILL
SWORN TO PROTECT DOING SO WILL
FURTHER THE OVERRIDING BONES OF
THE JUVENILE COURT TO AVOID
FAMILY SEPARATION WHENEVER
POSSIBLE TO KEEP CHILDREN OUT
OF FOSTER CARE WHENEVER
POSSIBLE. LOOK AT DIFFERENTIAL
RESPONSES AND COURT HEARINGS
EMPLOYMENT TRAUMA INFORMED
PRACTICES DURING OPPRESSION
LOANS TO STRENGTHEN AND RESTORE
FAMILIES THROUGH THE PROVISION
OF SOCIAL SERVICES WE CAN
DEVELOP PEACEFUL AND ALLOW THEM
TO COMMUNITIES. THANK. YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD.
THANK YOU. AT THIS MOMENT- WE
ARE MOVING ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE THREE
SEVEN BEGINNING AND ROUTE FORTY
TWO ZERO THREE SEE NON. MOVING
ON TO ROUTE TWENTY FORTY. NONE
THERE AND NOW WE'RE MOVING ON
TO THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE.
FIVE THREE SEVEN. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE IN
BENNINGTON ZERO. AND WE WILL GO
TO THE FIRST LINE OF FOUR
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOR
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GO
AHEAD YOU MAY SPEAK. HEY WE
HAVE ONE MARIN CUTE HERE
WAITING FOR THEM TO GET THEIR
NUMBER. ONCE AGAIN THAT'S ONE
THEN ZERO IN SUPPORT. HOLD ON
WE HAVE ONE FROM ONE NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS ESTHER PALLISTER EGGMAN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF NEXT DOOR
SOLUTIONS TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
IN SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA SERVING
SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND BEYOND
WE WANT TO REGISTER A STRONG
SUPPORT FOR SENATE BILL FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN AND THANK SENATOR
RUBIO AND HER SUPPORTERS ON
THIS IMPORTANT BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY MORE IN THE QUEUE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK MODERATE
AB HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW MOVE
OVER TO. THOSE THAT ARE IN
OPPOSITION WE DON'T HAVE ANY
KNOWN- LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. WILL
MOVE TO FORTY TWO OR THREE FOR
THOSE WHO ARE WILL. THREE NINE
ARE MOVING ON TO. A TWENTY
FORTY UP FOR ALL THOSE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN A PUBLIC COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THREE NINE- DO WE HAVE ANY AND
THE- ON THE LINE WATER HEATER.
AND IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO AT THIS
TIME. CAN I AM NOT SHOWING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT THANK YOU AT THIS MOMENT
TO- WHAT DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE BILL.
CAN WE HAVE A COMMENT OF FROM
OUR VICE CHAIR. AS ONE OF THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR MENTIONING THE-
THE WORK THAT STILL LITTLE BIT
OF WORK THIS SOMETHING'S DON
AND SO. I'LL SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY AND I AM ON JUDICIARY
WHICH IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING AT
THE SAME TIME THIS COMMITTEES
HEARING IS GOING ON SO IF
THERE'S ANYTHING I CAN DO TO BE
HELPFUL- THERE LET ME KNOW.
HELLO THANK CAMPUS. THANK YOU
MR VICE CHAIR WE- HAVE A MOTION
SOLD AT SENATOR REVIEW WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YES THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- THIS IS JUST
AN IMPORTANT STEP. WILL BE FOR
TO TRY TO RESOLVE THE ISSUE OF
FAMILY SEPARATION AND- PUTTING
OUR CHILDREN INTO THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM THAT SOMETIMES. IS
MORE DETRIMENTAL THAN THEIR
CURRENT CIRCUMSTANCE SO I AM
FULLY COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS AND WORKING
WITH. SENATOR JONES AND MAKING
SURE THAT THIS IS THE BEST
POSSIBLE BILLS WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL
THINK KILL. CAN WE HAVE A
MOTION CONSULTING Q. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SB FIVE SB FIVE
THREE SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY HER TADO
I FURTADO I'D JONES. JONES BY
CORTES ET BY CORTEZ THE I. COM
LONGER HI COM LONGER I'D PAN.
FAN I. THE VOTE IS FIVE ZERO IN
THE BILL IS OUT. THANK YOU
SEVEN PM. ALL RIGHT.
THIS
MOMENT WE ARE WAITING FOR AN
AFTER TO PRESENT WE DO HAVE
SENATOR CORTEZ HE HERE- THAT
HAS A BILL COMING UP- AND HIS
WITNESSES ARE ON THE CALL SO WE
WILL. AT THIS POINT ALLOW US TO
RECRUIT AS YOU DID TO PRESENT
HIS BILL. BUT THERE. OKAY
THAT'S FINE OKAY WELL THE FIRST.
ALL RIGHT ON BACK TO BE R. D.
THE ORIGINAL- GENDA- THE WAY
THAT IT'S FORMATTED ANYWAYS- WE
HAVE CENTER WILL HERE. READY TO
PRESENT ON AGENDA ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN THANK YOU SURE. UCSB FIVE
FORTY SIX WHICH EXTENDS THE AYE
FOSTER PILOT PROGRAM IS PART OF
THE C. P. UC'S BROADER LIFELINE
PROGRAM AT FIRST WHEN I THINK
THE CHAIR THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR WORK ON THE BILL HI THIS
BILL WILL ENSURE THAT THE C. I
JUST LIKE TO CALL PC CONTINUES
TO PROVIDE CRUCIAL
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICES TO
OUR FOSTER YOUTH. L. A. COUNTY
PORTION MY DISTRICT IS ACTUALLY
HOME TO ONE OUT OF EVERY THREE
FOSTER YOUTH IN L. A. COUNTY.
AND SO I'M WELL AWARE OF THE
NEED FOR THIS PROGRAM TO
CONTINUE. GIVEN THE STATE'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO CARE FOR ITS
FOSTER YOUTH IN THE FACT THAT
THIS PILOT PROGRAM ENDS IN A
FEW SHORT MONTHS. THE
LEGISLATURE MUST TAKE ACTION TO
ENSURE THE FOSTER YOUTH HAVE
CONTINUED ACCESS TO THIS
INVALUABLE RESOURCE. WITH ME
TODAY OVER THE PHONE TO PROVIDE
EXPERT TESTIMONY AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ON THE PILOT PROGRAM.
HISTORY TO **** THE CEO AND CO
FOUNDER OF AYE FOSTER THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATOR OF THE
PILOT PROGRAM. TO HAVE THREE ON
THE LINE. IF YOU'RE ON THE LINE
THE LINE IS OPEN. YES I'M HERE
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE I FOSTERED AND OUR
PARTNER SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE
FORTY SIX MY NAME IS THERESA
**** AND I AM THE CEO AND CO
FOUNDER OF AYE FOSTER AND A
FORMER BOSS TO USE. I TALKED TO
THE NATIONAL NONPROFIT
PROVIDING OVER A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE MILLION IN
RESOURCES TO TALK TO YOU
ANNUALLY ACROSS ALL FIFTY
STATES. ACCESS TO RELIABLE
COMMUNICATIONS IS A TRUE A
LIFELINE FOR OUR USE. THIS IS
WHY I AM PROUD TO SAY THAT THE
FIRST PROGRAM IN THIS COUNTRY
TO PROVIDE EQUITABLE RELIABLE
COMMUNICATIONS FOR COST TO YOU.
IS A SUCCESS. PROVIDING A TOTAL
OF THIRTEEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND THIRTY USED. WITH
ACCESS IN CALIFORNIA. LAUNCHED
MID NOVEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN IN
JUST SIXTEEN MONTHS THE AYE
POSTER PHONES FOR FOSTER YOUTH
LIFELINE PILOT HAS PROVIDED
COMMUNICATIONS FOR ELEVEN
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND TEN
TALK TO YOU. MEETING THE NEEDS
OF 70% A PILOT ELIGIBLE. FOSTER
YOUTH WE ALSO CONNECTED AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY SIX HUNDRED
PASSED TO YOU WHO WEREN'T
ELIGIBLE TO FUNDING FROM. CDS
AS AND PLAN TO BE. NO ONLY DO
NEARLY FOURTEEN THOUSAND. PASTA
YOU HAVE RELIABLE
COMMUNICATIONS THEY'RE USING
IT. I LIVE PARTICIPANTS USE
THEIR PHONES FOR COMMUNICATIONS
WITH FRIENDS FAMILY AND SUPPORT
NETWORK FISCAL WORK EMPLOYMENT
AND TELEHEALTH. 101% OF
PARTICIPANTS IMPOSTER USURPING
AGENCIES BELIEVES THIS PROGRAM
SHOULD CONTINUE. WHICH IS WHY
WE NEED YOUR SUPPORT SB FIVE
FORTY SIX. WELL THE CPUC DOES
HAVE PURVIEW OVER THE PILOT
DEFUSED ARE WARDS OF THE STATE
AND IT IS YOUR RESPONSIBILITY
IS SENATORS TO ENSURE THAT
THEIR RIGHTS TO COMMUNICATIONS
I'D GO TO FIGHT IN THE
CALIFORNIA FOSTER CARE BILL OF
RIGHTS ARE REALIZED. THIS
PROGRAM IS THE ONLY PROGRAM
THAT TOOK BOTH THESE RIGHT
INCLUSIVELY AND EQUITABLY. YOUR
SUPPORT IS REQUIRED TO ENSURE
THIS PROGRAM CONTINUES WITH NO
SERVICE GAPS AT SENATOR WILK
MENTION THAT WHILE THERE ARE
INDICATIONS. THAT THE CPUC WELL
WILL WILL RECOMMEND
CONTINUATION WELL ONLY SIX
MONTHS AWAY FROM PILOT AND
THERE'S NO COMMITMENT. NO PLAN
AND NO BUDGET. FURTHER NO PLAN
CRISP OUT PHONES IF THE PILOT
MORE TO CONTINUE. ON JANUARY
FIRST ALL PARTICIPANTS PHONE
WILL FEATURE TO WORK. BECAUSE
T. MOBILE IS SHUTTING DOWN THE
SPRINT NETWORK. THE PHONES OF
ALL THIRTEEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND THIRTY CALIFORNIA
PASSED TO YOU AS WELL AS THE
ESTIMATED TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
MORE YOU WE ANTICIPATE SIGNING
UP. WILL CEASE TO FUNCTION.
LOSING SERVICE CAN HAVE DIRE
CONSEQUENCES. AS ONE CALIFORNIA
FOSTER YOUTH PARTICIPANT SHARED.
I MIGHT HAVE COMMITTED SUICIDE
IF I WASN'T ABLE TO REACH OUT
TO MY SUPPORT SYSTEM WITH MY I
FOSTER FROM. IT COULD BE THE
REASON I FOSTER IN OUR HUNDREDS
OF PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA SUPPORT SB FIVE
FORTY SIX AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU ARE WE WILL BE
TAKING PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FOUR SIX
BEGIN AND ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE. C. NONE ARE MOVING ON TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. NONE THERE'S
WEALTH MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINE FOR
THOSE WAITING TO SUPPORT SB
FIVE FOUR SIX. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FOUR SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE WILL GO TO THE LINE OF
THE TWO FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF. SOCIAL
WORKER CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND.
THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO THE
LINE OF FOUR THIRTY TWO. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FOUR THIRTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. KIMMERIDGE ARE
BEGINNING AND IN THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH AND SUPPORT.
IT'LL BE JUST ONE MOMENT HERE
FOR OUR NECKLINE. WHAT DID LINE
UP FOR TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS KERRY GREEN
FROM ACROSS TO YOU IN SUPPORT
OF BILLS SB. FIVE FOUR SIX.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT LINE IS FOUR
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU IN CORK WITH
CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER
REPRESENTING THE CHILDREN IN
LOS ANGELES PLASTER ANDSACRAMENTO COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS VALUABLE
RESOURCE FOR OUR CLIENTS. THANK
YOU WE WILL GO TO THE LINE OF
FOR. REPORTER PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BRING A FOUR K. FROM THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE WILL GO NEXT TO
THE LINE FOR THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MINISTER OF INTERNAL ONE
THE FORMER BOSS USED BY THE
COURT SB FIVE FORTY SIX. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FELT WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYBODY ELSE IN PUBLIC
COMMENT. OKAY AT THIS POINT WE
WILL BE MOVING ON TO LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE
DON'T HAVE ANYONE OFFICIALLY-
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BUT WE
WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT-
BEGINNING. IN ROOM. FORTY TWO
ZERO THREE OPPOSED TO SB FIVE
FOUR SIX. ANYBODY ANYBODY ARE
YOU SURE OKAY. BROUGH TWENTY
FORTY. BUT UNDER EITHER SO OKAY
MOVING ON TO YOUR TELEPHONE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE. IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. AND IF
YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION OF SB.
FIVE FORTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. CAN WE DO HAVE ONE
PERSON KEEPING UP HERE ONE
MOMENT. ONCE AGAIN THAT IS
OPPOSITION TO ONE THEN. ZERO
AND WE HAVE MY NUMBER FOR
THIRTY FIVE. YES GO AHEAD.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
TURN THE UTILITY REFORM NETWORK
WITH AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE. THANK YOU.
FIRST WE HAVE NO OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE HERE OKAY
SILVA BRINGING THE CONVERSATION
BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
CENTER PAN. THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER WORK FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD- I GUESS THE-
SUFFERS WHAT CERTAINLY AM GOING
TO SUPPORT THE BILL. I GUESS
THE ONLY QUESTION AT THE SIR
THE QUESTION I HAVE IS IN TERMS
OF THE FUNDING SOURCE SO GIVEN
THE PREVIOUS FUNDING SOURCE I
REALIZED BY MORE PROBES
QUESTION IN THE END- BUT- YES
DO YOU FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT
THERE'S A SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
SOURCE FOR THIS YEAR HAS BEEN
IT'S BEEN FINE IT'S BEEN FUNDED
OUT OF THE LIFELINE AND THEY
STILL HAVE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS AVAILABLE. I KNOW IN
THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM. THAT
WE RAN- A DEFICIT LAST YEAR BUT
THAT WAS BECAUSE EVERYBODY WAS
AT HOME AND THEY HAD TO ACT
THEY HAD TO ACCESS ALL THE
DATA- FOR YOU KNOW. LEARNING
LEARNING ONLINE SO HOW WE CAN
MAKE THAT WE CAN MAKE THOSE
ADJUSTMENTS OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL
APPRECIATE YOU BRING THE BILL
FORD CERTAINLY WE WANT TO WRITE
THIS- SERVICES TO OUR FOSTER
USE ENDS UP HAPPENING. WITH THE
BUILT APPROPRIATE TIME THANK
YOU. IF THANK YOU CENTER PLANET
ADDITIONAL. OF ANY TOUGH
QUESTION. FOR THE FOR CENTER
WILL TODAY NONE. NO MORE OKAY.
ALL RIGHT US SENATOR. RICHARD
TO CLOSE. YEAH I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NINE. OKAY SO WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR PAT ON THIS
MEASURE AND CONSULTING Q.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB FIVE
FOUR SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS HER
TADO I HER TADO I'D JONES.
CORTESE BY WHATEVER THE I. COM
MARKER I KAMLAGER AYE PAN AYE
BANAI. PLAYS THAT MEASURE ON
CALL TO ALLOW OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE. MADAM
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THANK YOU.
OKAY AND ARE UP NEXT WE HAVE
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER NINE WHICH
IS SB FIVE FIVE EIGHT FIVE
CENTER COUPLE YET- AND I
BELIEVE SHE IS ON. HER WAY HERE.
OKAY AT THIS MOMENT WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND ADD THOSE- AT MEMBERS
TO THE CONTENT THAT WILL A
CONSENT CALENDAR UP UNTIL THE
PLEASE CALL- THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS AS BEFORE NINE
SEVEN BY THE MONNING SB FIVE
FOUR NINE BY JONES AND SB SIX
FOUR EIGHT BY HER TADO. JONES
KAMLAGER I COM LONGER I'D PAN.
HI AN HIGH. AND WE WILL PLACE
THOSE BILLS ON CALL LIST THE
CALL ON ITEM NUMBER TWO. SURE.
ITEM NUMBER TWO WE WILL OF THE
CALLED ITEM NUMBER TWO AS WELL
CONSULTING YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SB SIX SB THREE SIX FOR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS JONES KAMLAGER.
HI KAMARG ARE AYE PAN AM BY. WE
WILL PLACE THE BILL ON CALL AS
WELL.
RIGHT SENATOR KABIR WERE
READY FOR YOU. WONDERFUL THANK
YOU SO MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT SB FIVE FIVE EIGHT A
SIMPLE BUT IMPORTANT BILL FIRST
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR- GOOD WORK ON
THE BALLOT I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
IN THE ANALYSIS. SB FIVE FIVE
EIGHT WOULD ESTABLISH THE
FARMWORKER DISASTER RELIEF
PLANNING TASK FORCE TO PREPARE
FOR THE NEEDS OF FARMWORKERS
THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES FOR IMMEDIATE
INTERMEDIATE AND LONG TERM
SUSTAINABLE AND EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE SAFETY
NET SERVICES AND OTHER SOCIAL
AND AT ECONOMIC RELIEF DURING
DISASTERS AND PANDEMICS.
CREATING THIS TASK FORCE IS
CRITICAL FOR OUR STATE TO BE IN
A POSITION TO ASSIST
FARMWORKERS DURING THE MOST
CRITICAL TIME OF NEED AND
DURING TIMES OF DISASTERS
FARMWORKERS ARE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS AND ARE AMONG THE MOST
VULNERABLE. IN OUR STATE AND
WILL CONTINUE TO BE AS WE
EXPERIENCE CLIMATE RELATED
EMERGENCY VET EVENTS SUCH AS
WILDFIRES AND DROUGHTS LAST
YEAR FARMWORKERS SUFFERED
GREATLY DURING THE PANDEMIC
BECAUSE OF THE WILDFIRES WELL
AIR QUALITY ADVISEMENT
RECOMMENDED THAT CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS STAY INDOORS BECAUSE
BECAUSE OF REALLY POOR AIR
QUALITY FARMWORKERS WERE LEFT
WORKING IN THE FIELDS THEIR
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC SECURITY
WERE THREATENED. FARMWORKER
COMMUNITIES FEEL LEFT BEHIND
AND RIGHTLY SO THEIR
COMMUNITIES LIKE MANY RESOURCES
THAT WE TAKE FOR GRANTED
INCLUDING ACCESS TO CLEAN WATER
AFFORDABLE HOUSING HEALTH CARE
AND FOOD IN THE PAST FEW MONTHS
I PARTICIPATED IN MANY FOOD AND
PP DISTRIBUTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
DISTRICT AND I'VE SEEN THE
GREAT NEED TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO THESE HARD
WORKING FAMILIES AND TO ENSURE
SUCH ASSISTANCE IS PROVIDED IN
A COORDINATED. EFFICIENT AND
NIMBLE APPROACH AS YOU KNOW THE
STATE RELIES ON OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS TO DELIVER SERVICES
AND QUITE FRANKLY WITH SIX
COUNTIES THAT AS I WAS TRYING
TO GET INFORMATION ON- EXACTLY
THE BUCKEYE OF RESOURCES WERE
AVAILABLE. EVERY COUNTY DID
THEIR PROGRAMS DIFFERENTLY IT
WAS EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TO GIVE
ADVICE WHEN WE WOULD GET CALLS
FROM FARMWORKERS SAYING HAVE
THIS PROBLEM WHERE DO I GO WHAT
DO I DO. AND EVERY COUNTY HAD A
DIFFERENT METRIC THEY WERE
USING A DIFFERENT ORGANIZATION
AND IT AND MANY OF THEM FRANKLY
WERE LEFT WITHOUT ANY RESOURCES
AT ALL. THE LACK OF THE LACK OF
CULTURALLY RELEVANT INFORMATION
ON THE PANDEMIC AND THE LACK OF
ACCESS TO P. P. AND COVERT
TESTING. LACK OF ACCESS TO FOOD
DISTRIBUTION AND OTHER
GOVERNMENT ASSISTANT PROGRAMS.
CREATED ANXIETY AND QUITE
FRANKLY PANIC IN MANY OF THE
COMMUNITIES. WE ALSO SAW THE
NEED FOR BETTER COORDINATION
WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WORK WITH
FARMWORKERS. AND GOVERNMENT
PROGRAMS OFTEN OFTEN TIMES DID
NOT INCLUDE THEM IN THEIR IN
FOR THEIR INPUT. WHAT I PROPOSE
THAT THIS BILL IS A CALIFORNIA
DO BETTER. THE TASK FORCE WILL
HELP OUR STATE TO RESPOND WITH
AN EQUITY LENS. THANK YOU AND I
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
JOEL DERRINGER OF DERRINGER AND
ASSOCIATES AND A STRONG
ADVOCATE FOR FARMWORKERS HEALTH
AND SAFETY. DO WE HAVE FEDERAL
ON THE LINE. YES I AM OKAY.
PLEASE BEGINNING YOU ALREADY.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
SENATOR HER TADO AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR SENATE CUT BY ABOUT
QUARTER BEING A CHAMPION FOR
FARMWORKERS AND FOR THIS BILL.
IT WAS DESIGNED TO FORM A FARM
DISASTER PLANNING TASK FORCE SO
WE CAN LEARN FROM PAST
DISASTERS ADDRESSED THE
PRESIDENT OF FASTER. AND
PREPARE FOR FUTURE DISASTERS
WILL PREPARE CLIMATE RELATED
PANDEMIC RELATED OR ECONOMIC.
AS AN EXAMPLE THE DROUGHT IS
UPON US AGAIN WHAT PROJECTED
JOB LOSSES AND ECONOMIC IMPACT
IN AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITIES.
MANY LEGISLATORS HAVE ALREADY
WRITTEN THE GOVERNOR SEEKING AN
EMERGENCY DECLARATION AND THIS
WEEK BUT SHARES OF THE BORDERS
PORTS OF SUPERVISORS BUT SEMI
KING BALLY COUNTIES JOINED IN
THAT EFFORT. AS WE LEARNED IN
THE PAST. SPEND A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS IN
COMMUNITIES. THERE'S ALSO BEEN.
EIGHTY FIVE ZERO WELL MEANING
STATE TRIGGERED RESPONSES BY
MULTIPLE AGENCIES ARE OFTEN
WITHOUT COORDINATION AMONG THE
AGENCIES THEMSELVES AND
CERTAINLY WITHOUT COORDINATION
WITH C. B. A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION ON THE GROUND AND
LOCAL AGENCIES. SENATOR KABBADI
OTTO POINTED OUT THE STATE'S
MAJOR PARTNERS IN DISASTER
RESPONSE OR THE COUNTY
GOVERNMENT BUT THEY'RE ALSO
OFTEN DISPARATE RESPONSES-
DIFFERENT VERY DIFFERENT EVERY
COMMUNITY AND CERTAINLY AT THIS
CONNECT WITH THE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS. WORKING ON
THE DROUGHT WE FOUND THAT THERE
ARE MANY STATE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE BUT THE COUNTY HOW TO
APPLY. AND THEN SEVERAL
COUNTIES IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY THE COUNTIES DID NOT DO
SO LEAVING SMALL AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT RESOURCES.
IT'S ALSO A GAP BETWEEN STATE
ACTIONS AND THE ON THE GROUND
IMPACTS THAT ARE AFFECTING THE
INDIVIDUALS FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES. ACCESS IS IMPAIRED
TO THE LANGUAGE CULTURE
INTERNET ACCESS INFORMATION AND
AWARENESS TRANSPORTATION
TRANSPORTATION. THIS BILL
CREATE A PASSWORD SO WE CAN GET
AHEAD OF THE GAME- I WOULD HAVE
STATE AGENCIES COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
POLICY EXPERTS AND LOCAL AGOSTO
SI ASIAN. PLANT LEARN FROM PAST
DISASTERS IMPLANT PROCEDURE
DISASTERS THAT WOULD MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR RELIEF
PROGRAMS AND RELATED
LEGISLATIVE AND REGULATORY
PROGRAMS. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST IN IDAHO AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU-
BUT THIS ONE WILL BE TAKING
PUBLIC COMMENTED SUPPORT
BEGINNING AND ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE. NONE OF ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. NUMBER IS WELL AND- WILL
OPEN UP THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC
COMMENT LINE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. MODERATE HEARING SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ADVANTAGE
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
THREE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHE DIDN'T SHARE HER
TITLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS DIDN'T
KNOW F. BOTTOM ALL WITH
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION A PROUD
SPONSOR. AND ALONG WITH ON
BEHALF OF THE WEST MODESTO
COMMUNITY COLLABORATIVE IN
STRONG SUPPORT SB FIVE FIVE
EIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I NUMBER
FOUR FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CHRIS
RESPONSES POLICY ADVOCATE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW BARBIE
WERE PROUD TO BE PART OF THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE WILL NOW GO TO LINE NUMBER
THREE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M I'M SURE MEMBERS
ENTER SHANE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS IN
SUPPORT. WE DO HAVE ONE MORE
QUEUING UP HERE AND JUST GIVE
IT A SECOND FURTHER LINE NUMBER.
A LINE NUMBER ONE SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOLLOWING
MEMBERS JOHNNY PINERA ON BEHALF
OF BLACK ABOUT YOUR COMPANY YOU
KNOW THE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE FIVE EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY MORE COMMON IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU AT THIS MOMENT WE
INVITE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO TESTIFY. AND WE DON'T HAVE
ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION RECORD AT THIS
MOMENT BUT WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL BEGINNING WITH THROUGH
FORTY TWO OR THREE. TO HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION SEEING NINE TWENTY
FORTY. NUMBER EITHER. AND WE
WILL TURN IT BACK TO THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT LINE
IN OPPOSITION A POLICE- JUST
WANTED TO BE ON FOR SIZE BLOOD
NAME ORGANIZATION A POSITION ON
THE BILL. IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE FIVE
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
BENDING AROUND. MADAM CHAIR WE
HAVE NOBODY IN THE QUEUE AS OF
RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU. I WANTED
TO YOU KNOW THINK THE AUTHOR
THIS MOMENT- FOR PUTTING THIS-
BILL FORD AND I A KNOW THE
TRUTH. WE KNOW HOW DIFFICULT IT
HAS BEEN THIS THIS PAST YEAR
FOR EVERYONE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS WE'VE WE'VE ALL
STRUGGLED IN ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER. BUT PARTICULARLY IN
THE REGIONS THAT WE BOTH
REPRESENT- FEDERAL CALDERON
PLEASE FARMWORKERS ARE
HAPPENED- YOU KNOW WORKING
NONSTOP TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE- THAT OUR FAMILIES HAVE A
PLATE ON OUR ON OUR TABLE TO
THIS PANDEMIC AND- AND- I
APPRECIATE Q. ONCE AGAIN BEGIN
A FORWARD AND- I WOULD LOVE TO
BE A CO AUTHOR. OF THE PLOT. ON
THIS BILL UP IT'LL ALSO BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHO WANT TO. MAKE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS HERBAL
DESIGNER CORTESE'S CENTER COME
UNDER. SO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION FOR THE BILL'S
WELLS- IN EVEN FROM A DISTRICT
PERSPECTIVE- SOME PEOPLE UP
FORGET I KNOW THAT YOU'RE AWARE
OF IT- SENATOR BUT SENATOR
KELLY SAW HIS FIFTEEN THOUSAND
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS IN BY THE
GREAT. HONOR OF BEING INVOLVED
IN HELPING TO STAND UP BERMAN
THE WHAT'S NOW CALLED THE
CENTRAL- CENTRAL CALIFORNIA.
OUR CENTRAL COAST FARMWORKERS
CENTER WHICH DEALS WITH FOR.
AREAS FOR COUNTIES SO INCLUDING
THE SALINAS AREA OF COURSE
WHICH IS WHERE IT'S LOCATED- IN
IT JUST STRIKES ME THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS THERE THAT-
THE ORGANIZATIONS LIKE UNITED
FARM WORKERS HAVE SET UP THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO COMMUNICATE
IN TO. HELP PEOPLE- BUT-
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY WAS A
DISCONNECT- EARLY IN THE
PANDEMIC AND PERHAPS WHEN THEY
CONTINUED FRANKLY THROUGH THIS
DAY IN TERMS OF. OF I THINK
WHICH WHICH CREATED AN OUTCOME
OF THIS BEING REALLY SORT OF A
FORGOTTEN GROUP OF FRONTLINE
WORKERS TO SOME DEGREE SO I ATE
A TO APPRECIATE. WHAT YOU'VE
DONE HERE IN THE- YOU'VE TAKEN
SOME AFFIRMATIVE STEPS TO
ADDRESS THAT LONG TERM. IN AYE
AYE TO WOULD BE INTERESTED IN A
CO AUTHOR ON THE BILL OF UP
THAT'S APPROPRIATE AT SOME TIME
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU CENTER
CENTER COMMONER DIGITAL CENTER
PLAN HELLO THANKS RICH FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
WE ALSO HEARD AND HEALTH
COMMITTEE HAVE APPRECIATE IT
SAID JUST WRAPS ONE BRIEF
QUESTION AND I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE SOME MEN AND STICK IT TO
THE COMPOSITION TWENTY I DO
APPRECIATE THAT- AND THE
AMENDMENT DID MENTION THAT THE
FARMWORKERS WOULD BE ABLE AT
LEAST RECEIVE SOME
REIMBURSEMENT FOR EXPENSES
ATTAINTED A MEETING WITH-
PARTICULAR REASON FOR SENSUALLY
NOT. PROVIDE YEAH BASICALLY
SPECIFICALLY SAYING NOT THAT
TASK MEMBERS SHOULD NOT RECEIVE
A PER DIEM FOR SERVING. ON THE
TASK FORCE. WELL THAT WHAT MY
GOAL WAS IS TO UP NOT ENDING
HAVING TO BE HELD IN
APPROPRIATIONS QUITE FRANKLY
OKAY ANYTIME YOU START ADDING
COSTS ON TO THAT. TO THEIR
MEETING- EIGHTY RUN THE RISK OF
HAVING IT. THE BRAND TO RENT IT
COST TOO MUCH MONEY OKAY ALL
RIGHT BUT NO I APPRECIATE THAT
I MEAN I DO THINK THAT- YOU
KNOW PEOPLE TAKING TIME OFF AND
IT'S PRETTY THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY
AT LEAST PROVIDED FOR THE FARM
WORKERS BECAUSE- SOMETIMES THE
OTHER. YOUNG PEOPLE WE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO SERVE ON COMMITTEES
WHO MADE P. L. LOW INCOME THAT
WE WANNA HEAR THE VOICES AND
YET WE'RE GOING TO MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR THE SERVE BECAUSE
THEY'RE TAKING THEIR TIME
THERE'S EXPENSES ASSOCIATED
TENDING MEETINGS ESPECIALLY IF
YOU HAVE TEN A PERSON. AND
YOU'RE NOT LEAST REIMBURSING
SOME OF THEM IT MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE TO FULLY
PARTICIPATE SO I DID IT WAS
JUST LOOK HERE IS ABOUT THAT
AND GET SOME OF THE OTHER
MEMBERS PERHAPS ARE GONNA BE OF
BETTER MEANS BUT I'M NOT SURE
WE CAN ALWAYS ASSUME THAT. BUT
BUT OKAY THANK YOU AND IT IS
THE BUILDING MOVED. HAS AN
ELEMENT OF THE BILLS AND- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR PAN AND I%
APPRECIATE. THAT MY MIGHT. IN
IN RURAL CALIFORNIA IS THAT. I
EXPECTED THAT. MOST OF THESE
FARMWORKERS SERVING CBO'S HAVE
FARMWORKERS AS PART OF THEIR-
EITHER THEIR BORDER THERE THEIR
STAFF THEY DO WORK AND- USUALLY
THEY HAVE THE RESOURCES TO BE
ABLE TO PAY FOR IT TRAVEL AND
FOR PER DIEM- IT'S PART OF. HOW
THEY THEY BUILD THEIR THEIR
FINANCES. BUT I REALLY
APPRECIATED THAT THE COMMITTEE
CHECK. CALLING IT OUT AND
MAKING SURE THAT FARMWORKERS.
NUMBER ONE ACTUALLY DO END UP
ON THE COMMITTEE. I'M NOT NOT
BY HAPPENSTANCE IN NUMBER TWO
THAT THAT THERE ARE
RESOURCES THERE TO BE ABLE TO.
PAY FOR THEIR TRAVEL IN THEIR
PER DIEM. I THINK THE OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS ARE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO MEET THE NEEDS IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE AND-
AS I SAID. TRYING TO KEEP THE
COSTS DOWN BUT I DO APPRECIATE
IT AND THANK YOU. OKAY I. WE
HAVE A MOTION AND I SENATOR
COUPLE YOU DON'T KNOW IF YOU'D
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR YOU KNOW ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I'M HOPING
THAT WE USE IS THIS COMMITTEE
FOREST TO LEARN WHAT THE BEST
PRACTICES ARE I AGREE A 100%
WITH. CENTER CORTESE I THINK
THERE'S SOME. THEIR SYNERGIES
THERE IN SOME AREAS DID IT
BETTER THAN OTHERS AND WHAT WE
WANT TO DO IS TAKE THOSE
LESSONS LEARNED AND
INSTITUTIONALIZE SOME SO THAT
WE CAN USE THAT WE CAN PULL
THEM OUT MUSEUM. WHENEVER WE
HAVE A DISASTER SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE TO START ALL OVER
EVERY TIME WE HIT THIS POINT.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU CENTER
COUPLE YET- THE PROMOTION-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB SIX THREE POPE SB FIVE FIVE
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST DEMAND AND RE
REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HER TADO I.
HURTADO I'D JONES CORTESE RIGHT
CORTESE I CALL MARKER KAMLAGER
I'D PAN AYE MAN AYE. AND WE
WILL PLACE THAT BILL ON CALL TO
ALLOW OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ABOUT THANK YOU CENTER
CURRICULA. SO UP NEXT WE HAVE
SB SIX THREE NINE BY SENATOR
DORADO. AT THE GYM THE ITEM
NUMBER TEN AND I BELIEVE SHE IS
JUST. ON OUR WAY SHE'S RIDE
AROUND THE DOOR.
SENATE DRAWS
HERE WHAT WE ARE READY FOR YOU
SENATOR ALSO OKAY I'M HERE.
OKAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CAN
I EXTERNAL OKAY GREAT- SO I
WANT TO THANK THE FIRST THAT
THANK THE COMMITTEE OF VERY
MUCH FOR THE RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS AND- FOR THE
COLLABORATION SB SIX THIRTY
NINE ENSURES THAT WORKERS WITH
DISABILITIES CANNOT BE PAID
LESS THAN THE MINIMUM WAGE
SINCE THE NINETEEN THIRTIES THE
STATE HAS BEEN ON THEY HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO PAY WORKERS WITH
DISABILITIES LESS THAN THE
MINIMUM WAGE TO WHAT'S CALLED
THE ISSUANCE OF FOURTEEN C.
CERTIFICATES. UNDER THE FEDERAL
FAIR LABOR STANDARDS ACT THIS
PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED UNDER
THE ROOSEVELT ADMINISTRATION
WITH ARGUABLY GOOD INTENTIONS
WAR VETERANS WHO DEVELOPED
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
DISABILITIES FROM COMBAT CAME
HOME FROM ABROAD AND STRUGGLE
TO FIND EMPLOYMENT IN THE
MANUFACTURING ECONOMY. SAYS
WORKERS WITH DISABILITIES WERE
PERCEIVED TO BE LESS EFFICIENT
IN THOSE MANUFACTURING JOBS AND
THEIR PEERS. CERTIFICATES
ALLOWED FOURTEEN C.
CERTIFICATES ALLOWED EMPLOYERS
TO PAY WORKERS WITH
DISABILITIES LESS THAN ALL OF
THE WORKERS BASED ON THEIR
MANUFACTURING ABILITY OVER TIME
FOURTEEN C. CERTIFICATES
OFFERED EMPLOYERS A POOL OF
CHEAP LABOUR OF WORKERS WITH
INTELLECTUAL OR DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES IN SEGREGATED
SETTINGS ALSO KNOWN AS-
SHELTERED WORKSHOPS. FIVE YEARS
AGO THEY WERE 220-002-0030 FIVE
CALIFORNIA'S WORKING IN A SUB
MINIMUM WAGE ENVIRONMENT. THE
LAST PUBLICLY AVAILABLE FIGURE
HAD DIPPED TO TWELVE THOUSAND
IN EARLY TWENTY TWENTY AND THE
NUMBER CONTINUES TO DECLINE.
THE NUMBER OF CERTIFICATE
HOLDERS HAS ALSO DECREASED FROM
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO EIGHTY ONE AND
TWENTY TWENTY. DESPITE THE SIZE
OF CALIFORNIA THE STATE OF
ILLINOIS AND MISSOURI ACTUALLY
HAVE MORE. FOURTEEN C.
CERTIFICATE HOLDERS IN
CALIFORNIA SO IT'S CALIFORNIA
PRIDES ITSELF IN LEADING THE
COUNTRY WITH OUR FIFTEEN DOLLAR
MINIMUM WAGE CALIFORNIANS WITH
DISABILITIES ARE STILL BEING
EXPLOITED IN SEGREGATED
SETTINGS OFTEN FOR LESS THAN
TWO DOLLARS PER HOUR.
SEGREGATED EMPLOYMENT IS
ANTITHETICAL TO OUR VALUES AS A
STATE AND REINFORCES THE FALSE
NOTION THAT PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ARE UNABLE TO BE
INTEGRATED IN SOCIETY AND IN
CAPABLE OF PRODUCING LABOR OF
VALUE. THIS BILL PROHIBITS THE
ISSUANCE OF NEW FORTY C.
CERTIFICATES. BY JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND IT
DEVELOPS A PHASE OUT PLAN FOR
CURRENT CERTIFICATE HOLDERS TO
ENSURE A PATH TO COMPETITIVE.
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE THIS BILL WILL END
THE PRACTICE OF SEGREGATED MEN
UP SUB MINIMUM WAGE EMPLOYMENT
ENTIRELY. THIS IS A MEASURE TO
OFFER WORKERS OFFER DIGNITY TO
WORKERS WITH DISABILITIES AND
PROVIDE A PATH TO ECONOMIC
INDEPENDENCE CALIFORNIA CAN AND
SHOULD JOIN ALASKA CONNECTICUT.
MARYLAND NEW HAMPSHIRE NEW YORK
RHODE ISLAND TEXAS AND
WASHINGTON IN PROHIBITING SUB
MINIMUM WAGE EMPLOYMENT OR
SHELTERED WORKSHOPS. THIS IS A
RELIC OF THE NINETEEN THIRTIES
IT DATES TO A TIME WHEN
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES WERE
DENIED AN EDUCATION AND BEFORE
CIVIL RIGHTS LEGISLATION SUCH
AS THE AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITIES ACT WHICH
PROHIBITS DISCRIMINATION BASED
ON DISABILITY. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL JOINING ME TODAY ARE KEN
BARNES CEO OF OPTIONS FOR ALL.
AND AARON- CARRUTHERS FROM THE
STATE COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES- WILL DO A QUICK
INTRO OFFER TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND INTRODUCED OUR
PRINCIPAL WITNESS WHO IS JACKIE
ARMSTRONG. THANK YOU MANAGER
THANK YOU SENATOR DRAWS A
BEFORE WE MOVE FORWARD I JUST
DON'T WANT THAT- ASKED IT BOB
ARE YOU STOPPING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AT THIS MOMENT YES
I'M SORRY YES OKAY THANK YOU
RATE JUMPED OVER THAT YET. OKAY
AND THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO
JACKIE ARMSTRONG- VIA TELEPHONE.
RIGHT NOW RICHARD HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
THANK YOU PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. MY
NAME IS JACKIE ARMSTRONG AND
I'M HERE TO TALK TO YOU TODAY
ABOUT SB SIX THREE NINE. SO I
AM JACKIE ARMSTRONG AND THIRTY
FIVE I LIVE IN ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA. AND I. I AM ON THE
OPTIONS BACKGROUND. SO IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE. I HAD A JOB AND
THEN I LOST IT THROUGH THE
GREAT RECESSION. AND WHEN THAT
HAPPENED I WAS LIVING ON MY OWN
SO I. DIDN'T WANT TO LOOK BACK
AT HOME WITH MY PARENTS. SO I
WAS- LOOKING INTO SUPPORTED
EMPLOYMENT AS A POSSIBILITY IF
I COULD GET A JOB COACH BUT I
WAS TOLD THE ONLY OPTION WAS TO
GO TO A SHELTERED WORKSHOP CHAU
I TOOK THAT OFF- AND I WANT TO-
SHELTERED WORKSHOP. MY FIRST
DAY THERE I WAS GROWING UP ON
BOTH. BECAUSE THERE WAS NO WORD
COMING IN BASICALLY WHAT THAT
MEANS IS WHEN YOU'RE TRAINING
YOU SCREWED NOT ON BOTH AND YOU
DON'T GET PAID FOR THE ENTIRE
DAY- WHEN WORK IS COMING IN
THOUGH. WE USUALLY DID LIKE
PACKAGING JOHN ASSEMBLY AND IT
WAS VERY MUCH BY PRODUCTIVITY
SO- HOW FAST YOU WANT HAD.
EVERYTHING TO DO WITH THAT SO
YOU COULD YOU KNOW GO VERY VERY
FAST TO MAKE THIRTY MISTAKES
AND GET PAID MORE THAN SOMEONE
THAT WAS VERY METICULOUS. AND
THINGS LIKE THAT- THEN I GOT
PROMOTED- SO I WAS WORKING ON-
FROM SWEET WHERE I PACKAGE
DATES AND RAISINS AND THINGS
AND THEIR WEIGHT AT THE TIME
WAS ABOUT EIGHT DOLLARS AN HOUR
AND I WAS MAKING ABOUT FIVE
DOLLARS AN HOUR. AND THEN I GOT
PROMOTED TO WORK AT A- WORK IN
THE ELECTRONICS WHERE I BUILT
MEDICAL DEVICES IN MY ARM. THE
TASK BUT I DID- OR MUCH MORE
COMPLEX BUT BECAUSE OF THE-
PRODUCTS IN THE- THAT WAS IN
PLACE. I ACTUALLY GOT PAID GLAD
BECAUSE OF HOW METICULOUS AND
CAREFUL I WAS BEING OUT THE JOB
SO I GOT A PROMOTION BUT I GOT
DOCTOR A FIFTY CENT- AND THEN
THERE'S ALSO THE ASPECT OF- I
DIDN'T FEEL LIKE I WAS BEING
UTILIZED- SO MY CAPABILITY
INFORM MY- AND I DIDN'T FEEL I
WAS GROWING MUCH I LOVE HER. IN
FACT I WOULD ACTUALLYBEING
BULLIED QUITE A BIT FROM PEOPLE
WITHOUT DISABILITIES AND I
BEGAN TO FEEL VERY SMALL AND
YOU KNOW GOT TO A POINT WHERE
ANYBODY THAT WAS HER TYPICAL
THAT WASN'T MY FAMILY OR MY
APARTMENT STAFF JIMMY WAS THE
POTENTIAL BECAUSE OF HOW BADLY
I WAS BEING. WHEN I WAS OUT
THERE SHELTERED WORKSHOP- I
BELIEVE- IS STRONGLY ABOUT
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
DESERVES THE RIGHT TO HAVE THE
SAME CHOICES- AS EVERYBODY ELSE
BUT THE FIRST CHOICE OF THE
ENTRY SHOULD NOT BE GO TO THE
SHELTER WORKSHOP THAT YOU'RE
ONLY THAT'S YOUR ONLY CHOICE TO
WORK IT SHOULD BE WHERE DO YOU
WANT TO WORK LIKE YOU WANT TO
WORK AT RANGE YOU WANT TO WORK
IN AN OFFICE YOU KNOW IT
SHOULDN'T JUST BE SHELTERED
WORKSHOP. OR NOTHING- AND- THEY-
WE DESERVE TO BE PAID. THE SAME
WAY THAT EVERYBODY ELSE DIES.
AND SO I'D LIKE TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT- WITH MY REMAINING
TIME SO NOW I DO NOT WORK
INITIAL WORKSHOP ANYMORE I
ACTUALLY WORK AT THE-
SACRAMENTO UTILITY DISTRICT-
SMOG AND I MAKE A LOT MORE THAN
MINIMUM WAGE MY COWORKERS ARE
WONDERFUL I DON'T GET BULLIED
AT ALL AND I LOVED EVERY MINUTE
BEHIND THEIR- THANK YOU AND I.
REQUEST I VOTE. THANK YOU AND
WE ALSO HAVE- ANOTHER WITNESS
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT CAN
BARNES. THANK YOU SENATOR UP
WELL MY.
NAME IS KEN BARNES AND
THE PRESIDENCY. OUR COMPANY
HEALTH SEVERAL BUSINESSES
MANAGE FOURTEEN C. SUB MINIMUM
WAGE CERTIFICATES AND SOME
FAMILY MEMBERS SEE THESE JOBS
AS VALUABLE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
TRAINING AND SOCIAL ENGAGEMENT.
BUT WHILE I AM NEW TO THIS
INDUSTRY- MY TWIN BROTHER LIVED
WITH CEREBRAL PALSY SO I CAN
APPRECIATE THE GENUINE LOVE. M.
A. EMOTION CONNECTED TO THIS
ISSUE- WHAT I DISCOVERED AFTER
BECOMING CEO IN FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY IS THAT FOURTEEN C.
CERTIFICATES OFTEN TOOLS FOR
EMPLOYERS. TO LEGALLY EXPLOIT
THE LABOR OF PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES SO I BANDAR
SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN C.
CERTIFICATES. FIND THE MARKET
RATE JOBS IT'S NOT EASYBUT
WITH DILIGENCE AND HARD WORK ON
BEHALF OF THOSE WE SERVE WE CAN
TRANSITION PEOPLE TOO
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT IN FACT. SINCE WE
PANNED FOURTEEN C. SUPPORTS
LAST YEAR WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
PLACE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
PEOPLE INTO MARKET RATE JOBS
AND THAT'S DURING A PANDEMIC.
HOW DO WE DO THAT INSTEAD OF
BACKING EMPLOYERS TO HIRE
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WE
TELL POTENTIAL EMPLOYERS ABOUT
THE BENEFITS OF HAVING A-PHENOMENAL EMPLOYEE. AND THE
RESPONSE HAS BEEN EXCELLENT- IN
CLOSING I'LL SEE THIS OF MY
AREA STUDY IN COLLEGE WHAT WAS
HUMAN RIGHTS ANNABEL STUDENT
ONCE ASKED HER PROFESSOR HOW DO
YOU DEFINE A HUMAN RIGHTS AND
HIS RESPONSE WAS A HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATION. HIS RESPONSE WAS I
KNOW WHEN I SEE IT AS THE SOUP
LAST YEAR WHEN I HAD LEARNED
THAT IS LEGAL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE PESO ONE THREE
FOUR FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR. FOR
WORK I KNEW THAT WAS A- A HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATION AND I HOPE YOU
SEE IT THAT WY TOO AND I ASK
THAT YOU VOTE YES ON SB. SIX
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
TIME. BRING YOU FOR TRUST HERE
TODAY I WILL BE MOVING ON TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX THREE NINE BEGIN FORTY TWO
OR THREE. SEE NON MOVING TO
ROUTE TWENTY FORTY. NONE
THERE'S WHILE- OPERATOR KEEP
PLEASE OPEN UP THE TELEPHONE A
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE IN SUPPORT
OF. SB SIX THREE NINE. RELATING
TO COMMENT SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY
NINE IN A PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
CRIME. OFFICE TO GO TO LINE.
FOR FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS RICARDO. I AM
ACTUALLY A FORMER MEMBER OF THE
STATE COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES EMPLOYMENT BURST
COMMITTEE- BECAUSE AT THAT TIME
I ALSO SERVED ON THE SERVER
MARKET WE'RE ONLY TAKING ME
MORGAN IS A SHOULD A POSITION
ON THE BILL AT THIS MOMENT I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT. WELL THAT'S
YOUR PROBLEM AND I ASTRONOMICAL
FINE. IT IS A TWO NINE THREE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND WE WANT TO LINE FOR
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARTY AMATO
I'M A FAMILY MEMBER I WORKED IN
A DIRECT A MINUTE SHELTER
WORKSHOP OR FORTY YEARS AGO- HE
CAN CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
COMMUNITY ACTION NETWORK.
pSTRONG STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL IT'S ABOUT JUSTICE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ONE TWO FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
APPROPRIATIONS BILLS WORKER
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG.
THANK YOU. IT'S GOING TO GO TO
LINE FOR FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE FOUR THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES THANK
YOU MY NAME IS JUDY MARKHAM
PRESIDENT OF DISABILITY VOICES
UNITED IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S.
B. THIRTY NINE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANKS TO THE TIMELINE FOR
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. KAREN
MEMBERS NOT BROUGHT ON BEHALF
OF THE TEACHERS AMALGAMATED
TRANSIT UNION IPTV LOCAL TWENTY
AND TWENTY ONE MACHINE UNITE
HEARING UTILITY WORKERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE- BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MEXICO TO
LINE FOR FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS TREAT THE
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE ARK
AND UCPE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION- WE HAVE A
SUPPORT AMENDED POSITION ON THE
BILL AND WE APPRECIATE AUTHORED
AND SPONSORED FOR WORKING WITH
THE CHILDREN'S ARE CONCERNED.
THANK YOU. TO GO TO MINOR. ONE
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS
IS RALPH BLACK WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA STATE
EMPLOYEES WITH DISABILITIES YOU
CAN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIX
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU. SHE
MEXICO TO LINE THREE FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS DAN- CONFESSED
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIX THREE NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT IN
LINE TO LINE TO THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY-
THREE TWENTY EIGHT LINE THREE
TWENTY EIGHT PEOPLE HAVE. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS ERIN
EVAN ON BEHALF OF THE CULT
ADMINISTRATORS OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
YOUR TIME LINE FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS BY DESIGN YOU KNOW AND I
THOUGHT THAT IT AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR I INTEGRATED
RESOURCE AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL BUT I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE NOT AS AMENDED I
KNOW THAT THERE WAS AMENDMENT-
PRESENTED IN YOUR AND SUPPORT
OF THAT. I THINK IT WAS PRESENT
THANK YOU. CONNECT TO THE TO
LINE FOR SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE'RE PROUD
CO SPONSORS OF THE MEASURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. TO THE
TIMELINE TO TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I GET OUT OF MEDINA
ADVOCATE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
IS GROWING SUPPORTER SENATE
BILL SIX THIRTY NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE FOR
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS CURRENTLY
SEVEN AND I AM HERE TO SUPPORT.
SB SIX THREE NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AT THE TIME WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU SO
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION- AND I. BELIEVE
THERE'S THERE MAY BE SOMEONE ON
THE CALL UP HI CARL MUNDEN
PERHAPS JOHN. BOWL DO YOU HAVE
EITHER OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS ON
THE ON THE CLAUDIUS MANAGER YES
THAT KARL- I DID GET. OKAY
MA'AM. THE MANAGER MEMBERS
ACROSS LONDON HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE
SUPPORTING PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES TO
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION OF
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAM SERVING
THIS POPULATION WE CONTINUE TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL FOR THE
FOLLOWING REASONS. SB SIX
THIRTY NINE PROPOSALS TO CLOSE
ALL OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE OF
AB DE WHO WORK UNDER A LEGAL
FOURTEEN C. ARRANGEMENT.
WITHOUT ANY FUTURE PLANNED FOR
FUNDING SCHEME. THAT'S PRESENTS
A DIRECT CONFLICT WE BELIEVE
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT TENANT OF
THE LANHAM ACT ITSELF. DATA
PEOPLE WITH IBD CHOOSING A PATH
FOR HOW THEY BEST SEE THE
LIGHTS GOING INCLUDING GIVING A
JOB OF THEIR CHOICE MAKE NO
MISTAKE THIS BILL TAKES AWAY
THAT FROM THEM WITH NO SOLUTION
IN PLACE SECOND. ELIMINATION OF
FOURTEEN C. IN CALIFORNIA COMES
WITH NO DATA THAT ALTERNATIVE
SCHOOL WORK FOR THE LARGE
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE ON FOURTEEN
SHE PROGRAMS TODAY. STILL
TRACKS PEOPLE IN FOURTEEN HE
PROGRAMS AS ARE CLOSED BUT IT
DOES NOTHING OF VALUE IN
CURRENT PRACTICES OF TODAY
TOUTED BY THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL WHICH HAVE NOT PROVIDED
ENOUGH REALISTIC ALTERNATIVES
TODAY TO ACCOMPLISH WHAT YOU
ARE NOW BEING OUT TO LEGISLATE.
SENATOR ALSO COMPARES THE U. S.
IT COMPARES CALIFORNIA OTHER
STATES ARE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
FOR PEOPLE THAT YOU'RE WORKING
EASIER 86% THE UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE 86% WELL BELOW THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE. THIRD WORK
ACTIVITY PROGRAMS WHERE THE
CONTRACTED WORKERS BROUGHT INTO
A TEAM OF PEOPLE OF IDT TO
COMPLETE ARE THE CHEAPEST THING
THE STATE FUNDS AT ABOUT THIRTY
BUCKS PER DAY PER PERSON.
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT MUCH OF
THE WORK IN MEANS THE
pCLOSED THE STATE WILL ACCORDING
THE AUTHOR'S OWN WORDS MEAN AT
TWELVE TO FOURTEEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE HAVE TO TRANSITION. TO
MORE EXPENSIVE ALTERNATIVES.
AND COSTS UP TO COST TO THE
HUNDREDS FIVE MILLION DOLLAR.
AT A TIME WHEN THE STATE
ACCORDING ITS OWN. FIND
INTERESTING PROGRAM AT LEVEL.
WE STRONGLY URGE THAT YOU
ELIMINATE THE TERMINATION DATE
FOR THESE PROGRAMS WHILE STILL
PUSHING FORWARD. THE
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO DEVELOP
A PLAN. AND WE ALSO URGE YOU
ASK PROPONENTS IN THE
DEPARTMENT TO PRESENT MORE
FULLY. THEIR EXISTING DATA SO
WE CAN ASSESS WITH THESE
PROGRAMS CAN WORK AT THE SCALE
THEY'RE ASKING THREE DONE. BY
MILLER. WE TALKED FOR YEARS TO
SEE WHAT THEY NEED. TO JOIN US
AND HELP US FINDING EMPLOYMENT
FOR PEOPLE IBD WE ARE THE NO
VOTE AT THIS POINT HONESTLY SIX
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CARL- DO WE HAVE
GIAMBOLOGNA LINE. RIGHT
MEDICARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK. MY NAME IS JOHN BLAME
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR VISIBILITY
ON THE CONTACT OUT THERE HE- I
WOULD HAVE ELEVEN HUNDRED
PEOPLE TROUT CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY A WIDE ARRAY OF SERVICES
INCLUDING. THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
PEOPLE WHO ARE A RANDOM POINTED
SERVICES FROM CA JOB COACHING
TO WORK ACTIVITY PROGRAMS. AND
EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN. GRADES
AREN'T GOING TO SERVICES MIX OF
THE SPECTRUM BECAUSE
UNDERSTANDING AS SUCH IT'S
CRUCIAL TO UNDERSTANDING WHY
CLOSER STILL. HURRIED TO THE
PEOPLE WE WORK WITH ASK WHAT
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES IT'S
PARTY SIMPLISTIC CAPTURE ALL OF
THE NEW CHALLENGES. EACH
INDIVIDUAL FATE. THE TRUTH OF
THE MATTER IS THERE ARE VAST
DIFFERENCES IN BOTH THE MANNER
AND THE DEGREE TO WHICH
INDIVIDUALS ARE ENACTED BY THE
DISABILITY. IN ORDER TO BETTER
SERVE SUCH A BROAD SET OF
INDIVIDUALS. WITH THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE MUST BE AS EQUALLY
ROBUST. VISIBILITY WE OFFER A
FULL RANGE OF SERVICES TO HELP
PEOPLE ACHIEVE EMPLOYMENT GOALS.
BUT JUST AS MANY PEOPLE IN.
ABOVE MINIMUM WAGE EMPLOYMENT
AS WE DO ONE OF FOURTEEN STATE.
WE DO NOT FEEL ANY OF THE
PARTICULAR EMPLOYMENT SERVICES
THAT SUBSTITUTE. ONE ANOTHER
RATHER THEIR COMPLEMENT THAT
ENABLE US TO SERVE ABOUT THREE
PEOPLE ACCORDING TO THEIR NEEDS
AND I THINK ABOUT THREE OR THEY
CAN BE SUCCESSFUL AND THE DATE.
FORTY THREE IS THE ONLY PROVEN
MECHANISM FOR HELPING THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE HIGHEST
AREAS. ANY MINIMUM WAGE
EMPLOYMENT IF THEY EMPLOY.
OTHER LEGISLATION SUCH AS WE
OUR AND CALIFORNIA BLUEGRASS
HAS DIMINISHED THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WORKING UNDER FOURTEEN
FEET AS MENTIONED EARLIER.
DIMINISH THOSE THAT NUMBER DOWN
TO THOSE PEOPLE WHO. TRULY NEED
SUCH A SUPPORT. WE SHOULD NOT
AND CAN HIDE BEHIND BOTH. ALL
PEOPLE WORKING UNDER FOURTEEN
FEET TODAY OR EVEN A FRACTION
OF THAT WILL BE ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSFER THE
MINIMUM WAGE EMPLOYMENT. WITH
THE CURRENT RESOURCES WE HAVE
AVAILABLE. SO I HAVE TO ASK THE
QUESTION WHY THIS BILL USED
PRIME OF THE MILESTONE MARKER
FOR DISMANTLING FOURTEEN FEET.
OFFERS NOTHING MORE THAN THE
POTENTIAL OF A PLAN OR ITS
REPLACEMENT. WHAT IF SOMEBODY
SAID THAT WE SHOULD PASS A LAW
THAT. THAT DISMANTLE YOUR JOB
IN A FEW YEARS BUT NOT TO WORRY
BECAUSE THERE'S A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO
ARE PLANNING. FOR WHAT YOU GET
TO DO WITH YOUR OWN FUTURE.
WHAT WOULD YOU SUPPORT THAT.
THE BILL COULD YOU HAVE BEEN
WRITTEN THE STATE OUTCOMES
PEOPLE WHO CURRENTLY WORK UNDER
FORTY FEET AS THOUGH SAID
MILESTONE MARKERS. IT COULD
HAVE ALSO BEEN WRITTEN WITH
CERTAIN FAILED STATES. PEOPLE
SUCH AS STATE PROVIDING FUNDING
GAP THE WAIT BETWEEN THE
FOURTEENTH THE WAGE AND THE
MINIMUM WAGE. AGAIN WITH SUCH
EASY WAYS TO MOVE THIS THING
FORWARD. IT DOES NOT HARM
PEOPLE AND THEIR FAMILIES I
HAVE TO ASK MYSELF. WHY HI THE
PROPOSED AT THE MAZDA MARKER TO
DISMANTLE FORTY THREE. HI NOT
SAYING THE FOURTEENTH PERFECT
OR AT LEAST NOT TRY REPLACE
FOURTEEN SOMETHING BETTER. THE
CARD. I'M ACCORDING TO BILL
BECAUSE IT DOES NOT PROPOSED
REPLACE FOURTEEN HE WAS BETTER.
THE PROPOSAL IS TO REPLACE
FORTY THREE WITH A PLANT. NOW
CLOSED TODAY BY STATE THIS BILL
HELLO HARM TO SOME OF OUR
VULNERABLE. ARGUE WILL WE IT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE MOST
DIFFICULT CHALLENGES HAVING
THEIR VOICES HEARD. GIVEN THE
STATE OF THE PANDEMIC THEIR
INABILITY TO SELF ADVOCATE
SIGNIFICANTLY COMPOUND IT. THEY
HAVE DIMINISH THE COURTS TO
ASSIST THEM AND HAVING A VOICE
IS HEARD. SO TO PUT FOR THE
BILL. WE TARGET THESE
INDIVIDUALS DURING A TIME WHEN
THEY FACE TREMENDOUS CHALLENGES
AND SPEAKING UP. IN MY OPINION
ATROCIOUS AND YOU GIVE ANYONE
MORE THAN ENOUGH CAUSE TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL MOVING ANY
MOVIE ANY FOR THAT ALREADY.
THANK YOU GROWTH OPPORTUNITIES
BECAUSE I. THANK YOU- THIS CALL
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION. ON THIS MEASURE
WILL BEGIN- HERE FORTY TWO OH
THREE. THREE NINE- MOVING ON TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SANDERS
WHILE A MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE TELEPHONE
LINE FOR THOSE WAITING TO STATE
THEIR OPPOSITION. TO SB SIX
THREE NINE- JUST WANTED TO
REMIND EVERYONE THAT IT THIS IS
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
ON THE MEASURE. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SIX THREE NINE THE NEW PRESS
ONE THEN THERE AT THIS TIME.
AND WE GOT OUR FIRST LINE. FOR
SIXTEEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU ARE MELISSA CORTEZ
REPRESENTING AUTISM SPEAKS WE
SUBMITTED A LETTER OF CONCERN
WE BELIEVE THERE SHOULD BE A
PLAN IN PLACE PRIOR TO THE
PHASE OUT. THANK YOU. MEXICO TO
LINE FOR FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS VERY JOURNEY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SERVICES
ASSOCIATION YOU DON'T HAVE A
FORMAL OPPOSITION MISSED ON
THIS BILL- RATHER WE HAVE
CONCERNS AROUND THE TIMELINE
THE LOCK BOX ARE DEAD AND
MICHAEL FUNDING IDENTIFIED
HIMSELF THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. MEXICO TO LINE FOR
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS TRACY HOW INTERNET
FAMILY MEMBER OF AN INDIVIDUAL
AND I AM IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. AND THEN AT
THE TIME THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN
Q. THANK YOU MODERATOR AT THIS
MOMENT I JUST WANTED TO PROVIDE
A COMMENT ON THIS MEASURE AND
ALL I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACKNOWLEDGING THE AUTHOR'S WORK
ON THIS ISSUE AND HER
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING. THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY AT THIS
COMMITTEE. I THINK WE CAN AGREE
THAT WE ALL WANT INDIVIDUALS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
TO BE TREATED FAIRLY AND
EQUITABLY IN EVERY ASPECT OF
THEIR LIVES. INCLUDING IN THEIR
EMPLOYMENT. ARE CALIFORNIA'S
SYSTEM THAT SERVES PEOPLE WITH.
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES IS
COMPLEX. AND IT IS IT IS
INVOLVING TO REFLECT ON OUR
MODERN VIEW THE PEOPLE LIVING
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
CAN EXPERIENCE LIFE TO THE
FULLEST. WITH FULFILLING
COMMUNITY CONNECTIONS AND
REWARDING JOBS. I AM CONFIDENT
THAT THIS VISION CAN BE
REALIZED WITH THE SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES SYSTEM AS LONG AS WE
PROCEED WITH CAUTION- THE
QUESTION OF THE DAY IS HOW BEST
TO TRANSITION INDIVIDUALS OUT
OF SUB MINIMUM WAGE EMPLOYMENT
ANYWAY. AND ON THE TIMELINE
THAT ALLOWS THE SYSTEM TO
CREATE APPROPRIATE NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE WHO
WOULD BE LEAVING THEIR JOBS- AS
AS YOU HEARD TODAY THERE
CONTINUES TO BE QUESTIONS ON
THE ON THE MOST APPROPRIATE
TIME FOR THIS TRANSITION- ARE
YOU I WILL CONTINUE MONITORING
THIS BILL. AS IT MOVES FORWARD
AND REMAIN VESTED IN THE AND
THE OUTCOME. AND IT YOU KNOW TO
I ALSO WANT TO JUST REMINDED
HER BUT IT MADE THIS AT THE END
OF THE DAY IS ABOUT- AT. ONE OF
OUR MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE FOCUS
AND REMEMBER THEM AND BE
CONCENTRATED ON ON COMING YOU
KNOW. COMING OUT WITH THE BEST
SOLUTION POSSIBLE. AND I JUST
WANT TO RE EMPHASIZE THAT AND
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN GET THAT
DONE IF WE REMAIN. ALL SIDES
REMAIN FOCUSED ON THAT SO AT
THIS MOMENT I'LL GO AHEAD AND
OPEN. IT UP TO COME INTO
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. CENTER COME UNDER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MA'AM CHARGES
WANNA COME IN THE ON. FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL- YOU KNOW
AS I STATED BEFORE I AM THE
STEP PARENT OF A CHILD WITH
AUTISM AND I HAVE. BEEN IN THE
ROOM WHEN FOLKS ARE TALKING
ABOUT. HOW THEY'RE BEING PAID-
AND WHAT THEY'RE WORTH AREAS-
AND WHEN YOU DEVALUE A BODY OR
A BEING. AND YOU DON'T PAY THEM
WITH DIGNITY. AND WE HAVE BEEN
DOING THAT FOR A VERY LONG TIME
WITH THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY.
WITHOUT HONORING AND
RECOGNIZING THAT THEY ARE A
HUGE ECONOMIC CONTRIBUTOR AND
SO I APPLAUD YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I WOULD ASK AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. TO BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR AND AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I WOULD MOVE
THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. OKAY OUR SUB AS WE
WILL WE HAVE A MOTION AND THEN
SENATOR DRAWS WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE ON THIS BILL YES I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE NO PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES JUST WANT EQUAL
ACCESS TO THE KIND OF JOB
OPPORTUNITIES AND CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES AND MANY TIMES
SUB MINIMUM WAGE KEEPS THEM
FROM ACHIEVING THAT- I BELIEVE
THAT WE CHANGE WE CHANGE THE
TIME TO BE ABLE TO ALLOW SOME
MORE- PLANNING IN THAT- BUT IT
WOULDN'T TAKE EFFECT UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT SUFFICIENT
TIME TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THE
PLAN AND SUCCESSFULLY.
TRANSFERRED TRANSITION WORKERS
TO OTHER KINDS OF JOBS- AND
THAT'S A PLAN THAT WOULD
INCLUDE BOTH THE PROVIDERS AND
THE PARTICIPANTS BUT IT SHOULD
BE DONE AW YOU KNOW BASED AND
GROUNDED IN THE VALUES THAT WE
ALL BELIEVE IN- WITH REAL
CHOICE EQUAL RIGHTS AND OF
EARNED VERY POSITIVE POSITIVE
PATH FORWARD SO THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR WORK AND
MADAM CHAIR AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NIGEL THANK YOU. AT
THIS MOMENT WITH THE MOTION
FROM CENTER COME WALKER.
CONSULTING Q. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. S. B. C. THREE NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
HER TADO HI- TATO I'D JONES.
CORTESE CORTEZ THE I. COM
WALKER HI COM MARKER BY PAN. AM
BY. OKAY WE WILL PLACE THAT
BILL ON CALL TO ALLOW- OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO
THANK YOU COMMITTEE AND MADAM
CHAIR. YEAH AND UP NEXT BUT
THIS THE LAST BUT CERTAINLY NOT
LEAST IS A SENATOR- CORTESE ARE
HERE READY TO. PRESENT THE
SEVEN THREE NINE SO CENTER
COURT AS HE- I KNOW YOU COULD
GO FROM THERE. FOR FREE TO
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I THINK I'M
READY- MELCHER AND- SENATOR
SOME PLEASED TO PRESENT SB
SEVEN THIRTY NINE UNIVERSAL
BASIC INCOME. FOR TRANSITION
AGE FOSTER YOUTH. ACT A
TRANSITION AGE FOSTER YOUTH AS
WE OFTEN REFERRED TO AS TAY'S-
TA WHY STUDY AFTER STUDY
INDICATES OF. THE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED IN
NEARLY EVERY FACET OF LIFE WHEN
COMPARED TO THEIR PEERS IN THE
GENERAL POPULATION THE MORE I
COULD HAVE UNFAVORABLE
EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES. PHYSICAL
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES CONTACT
WITH THE JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT
WILL RATES OF SECONDARY AND
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION. TO NO
SURPRISE THE STRUGGLES THEY'VE
ONLY BEEN EXACERBATED BY COOK
BY THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. ACCORDING TO A MAY
TWENTY TWENTY POLL OF YOUNG
PEOPLE IN FOSTER CARE NEARLY
65% WHO WERE TRANSITION AGE.
FOSTER JOBS. MORE THAN HALF 53%
DID NOT RECEIVE A STIMULUS
CHECK. NEARLY ONE IN FIVE HAVE
RUN OUT OF FOOD AND ALMOST A
QUARTER 23% BUT WE ARE AT RISK
OR WERE AT THAT TIME OF LOSING
THEIR HOUSING. WHEN FOSTER
YOUTH REACH AGE TWENTY ONE. THE
MAJORITY OF THE RESOURCES THEY
RELY ON TO MEET THEIR BASIC
NEEDS ARE PROBABLY CUT OFF.
LEAVING THEM TO NAVIGATE
ADULTHOOD WITH LITTLE OR NO
SUPPORT. AS A RESULT ONE FOR
YOUTH EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS
AFTER LEAVING THE EXTENT OF
FOSTER YOUR FOSTER CARE
PROGRAM. ONE IN FOUR. HOMELESS
AS THE CHILDREN OF OUR STATE
FOSTER YOUTH ARE NOT ONLY
WORTHY OF INVESTMENT BUT IS OUR
OBLIGATION TO INVEST IN THESE
YOUTH AND SUPPORT THEM AND FIND
A STABLE PATH TO SUCCESS AFTER
EXISTS EXITING THE SYSTEM. SB
pSTATEWIDE UNIVERSAL BASIC
INCOME PILOT. FOR YOUTH AGING
OUT OF EXTENDED FOSTER CARE THE
PROGRAM WILL PROVIDE
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
WITH DIRECT UNCONDITIONAL CASH
PAYMENTS BUT ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER MONTH FOR THREE
YEARS. THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES WILL BE TASKED WITH
ADMINISTERING THE PROGRAM AND
CONDUCT AN EVALUATION UPON
COMPLETION OF THE PROGRAM. THIS
PROPOSAL CLOSELY MIRRORS A
SANTA CLARA COUNTY UNIVERSAL
BASIC INCOME PILOT PROGRAM.
WHICH IS CURRENTLY SERVING
SEVENTY TWO FORMER FOSTER YOUH.
FOR THE PROGRAM IS STILL ON
GOING INTO EFFECTIVENESS IS
STILL BEING MEASURED EARLY
FEEDBACK SUGGESTS THAT THE
PROGRAM HAS PROVIDED INCREASED
ABILITY FOR RECIPIENTS DURING
TIMES OF SUCH ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY. MORE MORE
MUNICIPALITIES ACROSS COUNTRY
YOU'RE CONSIDERING OR ALREADY
IMPLEMENTING A BASIC INCOME
PILOT PROGRAM BECAUSE OF THE
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS ASSOCIATED
WITH RECEIVING GUARANTEED
INCOME. THE CITY OF STOCKTON.
IS ONE MUNICIPALITY THE
RECENTLY CONCLUDED A BASIC
INCOME PILOT PROGRAM. IN THE
FINAL REPORT INDICATES THAT
RECIPIENTS EXPERIENCE IMPROVED
HEALTH AND HIGHER LIKELIHOOD OF
BEING FULLY EMPLOYED UPON
CONCLUSION OF THE PROGRAM AMONG
OTHER BENEFITS. AS A COPING
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WORSENS.
INEQUITIES AMONG OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE FOCUS OUR
EFFORTS ON FLEXIBLE. COST
EFFICIENT APPROACHES. LIKE
UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME WHICH
CAN LIFT INDIVIDUALS. OUT OF
POVERTY AND SET THE MOMENT THE
LAW TO STABILITY. SB SEVEN
THIRTY NINE THE PROVIDER FOR
SHE THE OUT OF WITH A LIFELINE
IS TO OF A FINAL COULD. AND SET
THE FUNDING FOR THIS SIX.
TRANSITION OUT OF THE CHAU WILL
FIRST. I HAVE WITH ME TODAY MS
JIMENEZ PER WHO THE SENATE CORE
COUNTY AND BASIC INCOME PER
PROGRAM. IN VERONICA VERA
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND
PARTICIPATED. OF THE COUNTY
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY IT
SPEAK ON SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
CORTESE WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE
TOWARD THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT- MODERATOR PLEASE BRING
ON TO THE PHONE LINE- MELANIE
MENDEZ PEREZ- FROM THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF COUNTY
EXECUTIVE AND THEN AND ALSO
VERONICA VERA SANTA CLARA.
SANTA CLARA COUNTY RESIDENT
AND- UPI PROGRAM PARTICIPANT
AND WILL BEGIN WITH A FELONY
DIMINISH PRESS YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES EACH MAXIMUM YOU CAN
TAKE LESS IF YOU WISH. SORRY ON
THE PHONE LINE YET. YES CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES THIS IS MELANIE
JIMENEZ PRESS. CORRECT THANK
YES OKAY PLEASE BEGIN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME I AM
EXCITED TO GIVE YOU SOME OF THE
INFORMATION ON OURPILOT IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY IT IS THE
ONE YEAR PILOT AND OUR AIM IS
TO REINFORCE THE SAFETY NET FOR
ONE OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. AND AS FORMER
SUPERVISOR NOW SENATOR CORTEZ
B. HAS SHARED WITH YOU HIS
LEADERSHIP HELPED US TO LAUNCH
THE PILOT DURING NOT ONLY A
MORE VULNERABLE TIME IN THEIR
LIVES BUT MISSED A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC AND I CAN TELL YOU
FIRST HAND I'VE MET WITH OUR
PARTICIPANTS AND THEIR RACIAL
YOUNG ADULTS. THEY HAVE SHARED
WITH US SOME OF THEIR DAILY
STRESSORS WHICH JUST REINFORCES
HOW PRECARIOUS THE STAGE IN OUR
LIVES ARE AND THEY STRUGGLE TO
TRANSITION TO ADULTHOOD AND ARE
ALSO AGING OUT OF FOSTER CARE
SERVICES WITHOUT PARENTS OR
FAMILY TO RELY ON. AS A
GUARANTEED PAYMENT STARTED TO
REACH OUR PARTICIPANTS WE
NOTICED A SIGNIFICANT SHIFT IN
OUR MINDSET THE NATIONALLY WHEN
WE FIRST REACHED OUT TO THEM
THEY HAD DESTRUCT AND ANXIETY
AROUND JOINING A CUTLET WITH NO
STRINGS ATTACHED WHICH COULD
POTENTIALLY. IMPACT THEIR
CURRENT BENEFITS. WITH
ADDITIONAL. OR IF THE
OPPORTUNITY MANY FOR PANICKED
ABOUT THE FUTURE. LAST WEEK WE
ISSUED OUR EIGHT MONTHLY PAY OF
ONE DOLLARS TO SEVENTY TWO
TRANSITION AGED FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH. FOR THE FIRST TIME I
HAVE NOT RECEIVED A SHIP CALLED
TEXT OR EMAIL FROM A
PARTICIPANT WHO WANTED TO KNOW
WHEN THE FUNDS WOULD BE
ACCEPTABLE AMERICA HELP. THAT I
HEARD FROM PARTICIPANTS WERE
HOPEFUL ABOUT THE FUTURE AND
WANTED TO KNOW WHAT ELSE THEY
COULD DO TO MAINTAIN THIS NEW
SENSE OF STABILITY AND
INDEPENDENCE. I THINK THEIR
TRANSFORMATION HAVE BEEN THE
MOST REWARDING EXPERIENCE OF MY
PUBLIC SERVICE CAREER.
PARTICIPANTS NOW KNOW THAT WE
AS A COUNTY SUPPORT THEM AND
BELIEVE IN THEIR POTENTIAL.
PILOT HAS TRULY BEEN A LIFELINE
DURING THEIR TIME OF GREATEST
NEED RATHER THAN THE MOORING
ABOUT WHERE THEY WERE GOING TO
SLEEP OR HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
EAT. THEY'RE PLANNING FOR THE
FUTURE. GREAT OPPORTUNITY WITH
SOME OF THEM FINDING THEIR
FIRST LEAGUE AND OBTAINING
STABLE HOUSING. SOME HAVE
RETURNED TO OUR BEEN ABLE TO
REMAIN I SCHOOL. OTHERS HAVE
PAID OFF THEIR DEBT AND FINALLY
SET UP THE PAVING THE COUNT.
AND FOR SOME THE FIRST STEP FOR
THEM WITH OBTAINING RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION. HELLO WHEN WORK
OPPORTUNITIES PRESENT
THEMSELVES. OTHERS NOW FEEL
THAT THE DREAM OF HOME
OWNERSHIP IS WITHIN THEIR REACH.
THEY HAVE DECIDED ON THEIR OWN
INDIVIDUAL PATH TOWARD SELF
SUFFICIENCY AND HAVE
VOLUNTARILY TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF
OPTIONAL PROGRAMMING SUCH AS
CUSTOMIZED ONE ON ONE FINANCIAL
MENTORSHIP BASED ON A
CURRICULUM DESIGNED
SPECIFICALLY FOR THEM BY OUR
PARTNERS THAT MIGHT PASS. AND
THEY HAVE BEEN PAIRED WITH A
VOLUNTEER CAN EXCITE CREDIT
UNION WILL HELP THEM ACHIEVE
THEIR GOALS AND CHECKS IN WITH
THEM REGULARLY THEY HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED SO MUCH IN A
LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME DURING A
PANDEMIC AND I'M EXCITED
IMAGINING THE POSSIBILITIES OF
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF WE AT THE
STATE PROVIDED THE SUPPORT
AFFIRMATION. TO ALL FOSTER
YOUTH YOU'RE GUARANTEED INCOME
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION I'M EXCITED TO
HAVE YOU HERE FROM ONE OF OUR
OUTSTANDING INDIVIDUAL PRODUCT
AND WILL SHARE HER EXPERIENCE
WITH YOU TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND JUST A REMINDER- WERE
ALLOWING LEAD WITNESSES AT
THREE MINUTES EACH AND UP NEXT
WE HAVE- FOR ANNIKA. WHOSE-
SHOULD BE ON THE LINE. I A. YOU
GUYS VERY YES WE CAN PLEASE
BEGIN. I THANK YOU I THANK YOU
GUYS FOR HAVING ME TODAY
ARMONK- BUT WHEN I GOT TO SAY
ABOUT THE PROGRAM IS IT IN SUCH
A SHORT TIME- AMOUNT OF TIME
THE BASIC INCOME PILOT PROGRAM
HAS BEEN ABLE TO HELP ME LEARN.
AND ACCOMPLISH THINGS THAT I
WAS A KID I LEARNED WHEN I WAS
TWENTY ONE. ALL THOSE THOUSAND
SOMETHING MILLER WITH THE
PROGRAM. IT HAPPENED TO START
RIGHT AROUND THE MONTH OUR
EXITING THAT- EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE. HOUSING PROGRAM WOULD-
BILL WILSON CENTER HERE IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY. HOW THE
READY TO SETTLE HOLLISTER. BUT
HOW WAS I GOING TO PAY FOR MY
BRAND BE ABLE TO MANAGE MY
BILLS. ABSOLUTELY. E. THEM
FOCUS ON SCHOOL. THE FINANCIAL
TO POKE WOULD BE INCOME PILOT
AND- EXOCRINE UNION. CAME INTO
MY LIFE LIKE A SUPER HE RIGHT
TO SEEK MY- I DISCIPLINE.
THANKS TO MY FINANCIAL MENTORS
BY STEP- HELP ME. TO
SUCCESSFULLY LEARN HOW FIX AND
BILL MY CREDIT. I THOUGHT
PLAYING GET A CAR CARD YOU HAD
TO MY WELL SELECT YOU HAVEN'T.
AFTER FOR MY RENT MY BILLS. AND
EVEN HAS EXTRA. TO MY COFFEE.
IT WILL IMPORTANT IF IT WERE
FOR BASIC INCOME PALETTE I
DON'T THINK I COULD HAVE AT
WORK BE ON. TO GRADUATE
SEMESTER FROM SOUNDS OF THE
UNIVERSE JERRY. READY GET A
CREDIT CARD FIX MY CAR THERE.
WITH MY CREDIT SITE- LAND HOW
TO SAVE MONEY AND GETTING
CONNECTED TO PROGRAMS AND
COMPANIES HIRE HIRING ON THE
PUBLIC HEALTH FIELD. I CAN ALL
I CAN HONESTLY SAY THAT MIGHT
NOT AT ALL A GOOD POINT NOT A
WHOLE LOT TO. TURN TWENTY FIVE
THEM FINALLY STARTING TO FEEL
LIKE AN INDEPENDENT. YOUNG
ADULT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SOME- AT THE SMALL WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN THREE NINE- FORTY TWO
HEARING ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
SEE NON ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
NUMBER AS WELL AT THIS MOMENT
WE WILL OPEN UP THE TELEPHONE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN THREE NINE
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
THOSE LINES UP INDIVIDUALLY. DO
YOU LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN THREE NINE IN A PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
GO TO LINE FOR TWENTY SEVEN
FIRST PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS KEVIN IN SCOPE WITH THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
THREE NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MEXICO TO LINE FOUR FOUR TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THANK YOU
SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE THE CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE TWO
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THE TO LINE FOR SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS COOK PASTA
ON BEHALF OF THE JUVENILE COURT
JUDGES OF CALIFORNIA WHICH IS A
SECTION OF THE CALIFORNIA
JUDGES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. YOU THANKS FOR THE
TWO LINES FOR SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT I DON'T MAGNITUDE
TEN FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO
MARIN FOOD BANK IN SUPPORT.
MEXICO TIMELINE FOR FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS JORDAN SOSA A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH AND CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION CALLING AND
SUPPORTED SB SEVEN THREE NINE
THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO GO TO
LINE FOR THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON CAN
LARA FOR PREVENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
AND THAT ARE NOT IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GO TO LINE ONE SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND
LIMóN DYNAMIC MOTION BOSHAM ON
WORLD WAR IN SUPPORT OF. SB
SEVEN. SEVEN THREE NINE AND- ON
BEHALF OF SOCIAL WORK- TOOL FOR
POLICY CLASS AT SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MEXICO TO LINE ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS DAISY BATON AND ALSO-
HERE IS JENNIFER T<c.cyan> I AM A</c>
MSW GRADUATE STUDENT TENNESSEE
STATE UNIVERSITY ALSO IN SOCIAL
WORK TO- FOR POLICY- I WAS ONCE
A MEMBER OF THE FOSTER
COMMUNITY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR THE TO LINE ONE
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS REALLY NOT FAR AS
A DIRECT MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
PROVIDER FOR FOSTER YOUTH AND
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE ELEVEN
THOUSAND- HOMELESS FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH AGES TWENTY ONE TO
TWENTY FOUR. AND THE POOR AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU. THANKS
TO THE TIMELINE FOR THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS JIM Q. CODIRECTOR OF
UNIVERSAL INCOME PROJECT BASED
IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB. SEVEN
THIRTY NINE. NEXEO TO LINE TO
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS PAIGE SALINE
AND A GRADUATE STUDENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL OF SOCIAL
WORK ON BEHALF OF ALL AB TWELVE
AS AGING OUT OF FOSTER CARE
SERVICES IN AN EFFORT TO ENSURE
THEIR HEALTHY DEVELOPMENT I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SEVEN
THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE NEXT LINE FOR SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OXCART
MEDICALLY GO ABOVE OUR BERMAN
BUST YOUR WORKING ACCOUNT WHEN
YOU COLLECTIONS ABOUT STRONG
SUPPORT BOB. THE BILL. THANK
YOU MEXICO TOTAL THANKS TO THE
TIMELINE ONE SEVENTY NINE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND I AM
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN
AND SON AND JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOU SHOWING
STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB. SEVEN
THREE NINE. MEXICO TO MIND TO
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
ABOUT A MEDINA ADVOCATE AND
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND THE PORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANKS TO
THE TIMELINE FOR SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GASKIN FROM
THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA THE ELECTED DIRECTOR
LEAR ORGANIZATION FOCUSED ON
EQUITY FOR CHILDREN I WANT TO
THANK THEIR COULD QUICKLY
KEEPERS BE TO SHIP ON SB SEVEN
THREE NINE AND LOOK LIKE. TO
URGE MY SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
THANK YOU HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS FOR OPPOSITION-
AND THIS AT THIS MOMENT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY LEAD WITNESSES
AND UP IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL BUT WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT- HE STARTED HEARING
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE. ANYONE
OKAY- THE C. NINE MOVIE NOT TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEEN ON
THERE AS WELL WE ARE MOVING ON
TO THOSE OPPOSED TO SB SEVEN.
THREE NINE ON THE UP PUBLIC
LINE I WANT TO JUST- REMIND
EVERYONE THAT IF THEY COULD
JUST STATE THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINES INDIVIDUALLY.
IF YOU LIKE TO COME IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN THREE
NINE IN A PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AT THE TIME THERE'S
NO WINNING QUEUE. OKAY THANK
YOU MODERATOR- I WILL UP BRING
THE COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND I
HAVE SENATOR PAT. THANK YOU
AND- SECRETARY ZERO WITHOUT
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORTUNATELY- PREVIEW YOUR-
PERSONAL X. EXPERIENCES WELL
AND THAT YOUR BRAIN TWO TWO
THIS IS MY ONE QUESTION IS
THAT- CERTAINLY SUPPORT WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO WHAT YOU'RE
DOING WITH THE BILL THIS IS
STERN- SOME ELEMENTS OF- I
GUESS FINANCIAL LITERACY
EDUCATION THAT THE WITH THAT
SO. PART OF THE PROGRAM I MEAN
I'M NOT TRYING TO CREATING
BARRIERS TO PEOPLE GETTING
THEIR UPI BUT- BE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE SOME FINANCIAL
LITERACY. BASIC FINANCIAL
LITERACY ABOUT BANKING AND
BUDGETING AND SO FORTH- AS- THE
WAY TO PREPARE- THESE FOSTER
YOUTH FOR. RECEIVING THE FBI IS
THE- FORD. WHAT A GREAT
QUESTION- THANK YOU CENTER PAN
THE- WHAT HAPPENED IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY WITH THAT PILOT AT
LEAST THUS FAR- IT IN SERVICES
PARTY INITIAL DIRECTION- ON IT
IS- IT THERE WITHOUT MANDATING-
ENROLLMENT ANY PARTICULAR
PROGRAM- THE COUNTY MADE SURE
IN THIS SHOULD HAPPEN AT THE
STATE LEVELS WELL SHOULD THIS.
BECOME A FULL FLEDGED PROGRAMS
STATEWIDE- THE COUNTY MADE
SURE. TO INVITE IN A TO REACH
OUT OF FOR PRIVATE SECTOR-PARTNERS BOTH ON THE NONPROFIT
SIDE IN IN ACTUALLY ON ON THE
PRIVATE SECTOR SITES SUCH AS
CREDIT UNIONS THAT THEY WERE
WILLING TO OFFER. AGAIN NON
MANDATORY LITERACY CLASSES- MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT MANY THE
FOSTER YOU SIGN UP FOR THOSE
SOME SOME WANT. THAT SOME
DON'T- HE AND- ASSEMBLY WITH
WITH ANGIE ARE C. POOR BUILD IN
THE COMMUNITY. AS WE ALL KNOW-
THOSE OF US- WHICH IS I THINK
ALL OF US HERE WE'RE FAMILIAR
WITH THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT- TO A
WELFARE SYSTEM- BECAUSE HE'S A
IF YOU HAVE BEEN INVOLVED. IN
HAD AVAILABLE TO THEM- MANY
PROGRAMS WRAPAROUND SERVICES
RIGHT UP TO THIS POINT WHERE
THEY REACHES FINANCIAL CLIFF-
THERE EITHER IN PRETTY GOOD
SHAPE GETTING THAT CAN HELP
SHOULD THEY WANT IT BUT HE HIT
THE NAIL ON THE HEAD THE IDEA
IS. NOT TO NOT TO MANDATE- IN
IT TO GET AWAY FROM THE NOTION.
THAT THAT SOMEHOW. THE SYSTEM
THAT FRANKLY WAS. GO INTO MORE
CONSERVATIVE- DAVE AND THEN MY
ILK- BUT WHICH WANTED TO
DICTATE- WHAT WAS GOING TO BE
BEST HI. ROSS THE BOARD ONE
SIZE FITS ALL YOU ONLY NEED
HELP WITH YOUR HOUSING OR YOU
ALL NEED HELP YOUR TUITION OR
YOU ALL NEED HELP THEIR FOOD
WHICH WE ALL KNOW IS NOT THE
CASE- THIS IS TAKES THOSE.
DETACHES OF STRINGS SO THAT
THERE'S A DEGREE OF
EMPOWERMENT. AND- HI WE HEARD
THAT FROM ONE OF THE WITNESSES
JUST NOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT ANSWER I DID. THINK IT
WOULD BE GOOD IF IN SOME WAY WE
COULD AND- SAID NOT CORPORATE
REQUIREMENT TO TAKE FINANCIAL
LITERACY AS MUCH AS THAT THEIR
ENSURE THAT FINANCIAL LITERACY.
CLASSES OR INSTRUCTION IS
AVAILABLE- TO THE YOUTHS- IN
CASE- DATE DEPENDING ON WHERE
THEY ARE AND SO FORTH JUST BE
SURE THAT DAY DID YOU HAVE THAT
AVAILABLE TO THEM ESTATE WHICH
TO- TO PARTAKE OF THAT IN
PREPARATION FOR A RECEIVING GUY
DID A U. P. EYES TO DATE MOVED
TO TRANSITION I THINK SHE'S ON
WHETHER TO GET YOU THE I OR
NOT- BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
LIFE SKILLS- BUT- IF SAYS. SO I
WOULD JUST ASSUME THAT AS A
SUGGESTION- CERTAINLY NOT AS
SOMETHING- BUT- SO IT WAS
SUPPORT THE BILL AND- IT WILL
MOVE ITS APPROPRIATE TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO WE HAVE. THAT
YES SIR CORTES HE WOULD YOU ARE
LIKE TO CALL. THANK YOU AND
INTEREST TO SORT OF INCORPORATE
A MORE AFFIRMATIVE RESPONSE TO
CENTER PANS QUESTION MY
CLOTHES- WE WILL SEE TO
INCLUDE. A PROVISION IN THE
BILL WHICH WOULD AUTHORIZE. THE
DEPARTMENT EXCEPT IN KIND
DONATIONS SUCH AS FIND OUT
FINANCIAL MENTORSHIP AND OTHER
SERVICES. BUT FOR THE PROGRAM
AND POINT IS WELL TAKEN AND-
I'M I'M GLAD TO HEAR. HERE YOU
BRING IT UP- WE UNDERSTAND
THERE'S AN APPROPRIATIONS ISSUE
HERE THAT NEEDS TO BE MET I
JUST WANT TO SPEAK TO THAT
THAT'S OFTEN THE CASE. WITH ANY
OF OUR LEGISLATION CERTAINLY
THE CASE HERE- BUT- THERE'S A
LOT OF EFFORT GOING ON IN THAT
REGARD SIMULTANEOUS WITH THE
INTRODUCTION OF THIS BILL ARE
CONCURRENT WITH IT. AND WITH
THAT BUT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE BOTH- GIVEN WE HAVE A-
MOTION A CONSULTING KEY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SB SEVEN THREE
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS HER
TADO I RETIRED- I'D JONES.
JONES NOW. CORTESE ALL RIGHT
CORTESE I'D CALM LONGER. PAN HI
AN HIGH. SO WE WILL PREFER THIS
BILL ON CALL TO ALLOW ALL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE AND AT THIS MOMENT WE
WILL- OPEN. THE CALL OFF- LOOK
LOOK THE CALL ON THE OF. ON
BILLS AND CONTROL THE CAN YOU.
THIS WILL START WITH CONSENT.
WE HAVE SB FOUR NINE SEVEN BY
LIMóN SB FIVE FOUR NINE BY
JONES IN SB FOUR SIX FOUR EIGHT
BY HER TITLE ON CONSENT JONES.
JONES BY. THE VOTE WAS FIVE
ZERO AND CONSENT- CALENDAR
ITEMS- ARE OUT. THEN ABOUT.
FIVE ZERO. OKAY AND UP NEXT TO
IT THREE SIX FOUR. SB THREE SIX
FOUR BY SKINNER THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED BUT FIRST BE RE
REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS JONES. JONES I.
THE BILL IS FIVE ZERO AND THAT
BILL IS OUT. NEXUS SENATE BILL
FIVE FOUR SIX. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SB FIVE FOUR SIX BY WILK
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE RE REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS JONES. JONES BY.
DIVO IS FIVE ZERO DOUBLE AS OUT.
UP NEXT IS A SENATE BILL FIVE
FIVE EIGHT PERCENT- CABALLERO
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SB FIVE FIVE EIGHT THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT- BUT
FIRST DEMAND HIM IN RE REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
JONES. JONES BY. THE BILL IS
FIVE ZERO AND THAT BILL IS OUT.
THE. UP NEXT WE HAVE THE SENATE
BILL SIX THREE NINE. CONSULTA
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
NOT SB SIX THREE NINE BY DORADO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST DEMAND AND RE
REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS JONES. JONES NO.
I WANT ONE. THE VOTE IS FOR ONE
AND THE BILL IS OUT. SUGARS.
OKAY UP NEXT IS SENATE BILL.
109% A QUARTET THE CONSOLE TO
KEEP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SB
SEVEN THREE NINE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE RE REFER
TO COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COME MARKER HI. COME LONGER I'D.
THE VOTE IS FOR ONE ON THE BILL
AND- THAT BILL IS OUT. OUR IT.
SO I WANT TO THINK I WANT TO BE
CALLED THE INDIVIDUAL
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY I HOPE
IT WAS A TRYING TO BE RUDE AND
UNKIND AND STREAMLINE IT AND
MAINTAINING- AT THE HEARING
TODAY BUT I HOPE IT IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE. OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS.
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND TO ME
WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY TO PUSH RECALL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION- AND YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA. FOR
THE SENATE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.